vous voulez partir votre propre podcast
vous voulez à mener celui que vous avez
déjà un autre niveau
ça tombe bien on loue le studio sf ce
merveilleux studio dans lequel je suis
présentement et dans lequel également on
enregistre le sans filtre podcast parmi
tant d'autres la plupart du temps ce qui
empêche les gens de sauter dans
l'univers du podcast est en croissance
constante c'est le manque de
connaissances techniques et aussi le
manque de matériel d'un qu'à cela ne
tienne dans le studio sf on loue le
studio avec tout le matériel donc tous
les micros tous les caméras si vous
voulez faire une version vidéo de votre
podcast et ça vient aussi avec notre
technicien extraordinaire nicholl
nicholl qui va vous guider dans votre
projet c'est probablement la personne au
québec qui écoutent le plus de balados
indépendant parce qu'il y ait derrière
la console surtout les balados qu'on
enregistre au studio sf dont il va se
faire un plaisir de vous accompagner
dans ce processus là si vous voulez plus
d'information au sujet de la location du
studio écrivez nous à sans filtre
podcast à commercial gmail.com
une production du studio sfr venu sans
filtre le podcast on parle de ce qu'on
veut de nous inviter date site
je suis pas content avec moi d'une
plante j'allais dire je perds quand avec
moi ph quand on y met et le podcast
cette semaine et présenté par notre page
piquionne donc sur pétrone depuis moins
de sept frères des podcasts exclusifs ou
est-ce qu'on est juste l'une d'eux qu'on
jase on va faire un prochainement des
prochains jours fait que si vous voulez
entendre plus de nous autres ben ben
allez sur pet urnes trois pièces par
mois vous avez accès à tout ce qu'on
voudrait avoir accès au studio va
continuer à faire des podcasts on va s'y
prendre plus d'avancé que vous allez
voir les podcasts en primeur perd même
temps c'est la meilleure façon
d'encourager le sans filtre cette
semaine donne
alors cette semaine on a reçu un invité
quelqu'un qu'on adore recevoir si le
premier éviter qu'on reçoit trois fois
ici
lévy bernard de pharmacie de nore dogues
lui même alors vraiment compter vraiment
content d'avoir eu à parler de sujets
ici de la fabrication de vaccins pour
économie russe les médicaments sur les
conflits terry de transpiration les
différentes théories son opinion là
dessus
après ce couac on a parlé ph on a
tellement parlé d' afrique je ne sais
plus on est revenu sur le lien entre le
poids et la santé qu'on avait parlé un
petit peu durant le podcast avec bernard
vallet catherine lefebvre effectivement
vers la fin mais toujours des cours de
conversation leur lien de près ou de
loin avec un peu la situation en ce
moment qui est toujours un look qui est
très intéressant à entendre beaucoup de
savoir beaucoup de faits scientifiques
dans son arsenal
c'était vraiment un grand plaisir
c'est tout le temps c'est le temps des
conversations complètement folle avec
olivier s'est massée sur des podcasts
qui me font triper le dis on n'a pas vu
le temps passer comme de fait c'est le
plus long qu'on fait un confinement le
temps d'être sur une base plus lentement
confintea cancon et sur zoom c'est moins
intéressant cdci moins engageant mais le
olivier était juste
toujours très très pertinent et écouter
on a abordé tellement de sujets on a
abordé des sujets qui sont polarisées
dans la société en ce moment même s'ils
sont polarisées nécessairement dans le
la communauté scientifique donc
probablement qu on a dit des choses
qu'on a abordé ce sujet avec lesquels
vous n'êtes pas d'accord
interagissez dans les commentaires dans
le respect on n'est pas ici pour se
faire traiter de reptilien fait que
laisser des commentaires like et si vous
aimez la vidéo laquelle a même si vous
aimez pas
[Musique]
j'encourage autres pièces non bon
podcast bonne écoute
[Musique]
yes salut olivier comment ça va ça va
bien vous offre pas bien comment
commence par ce confinement bas et c'est
un peu comme tout le monde le sait il ya
du bon et du moins bon avec beaucoup de
bouleversements beaucoup de stress mais
je pense quand même des super bons
moments avec ma blonde puis avec notre
chien puis lui aussi l'apport des mises
comme un moment en fait il n'y a jamais
eu autant d'intérêt pour tout les sujets
scientifiques lé dans un sens où toutes
les informations d information n'était
plus de job que jamais la belgique map
l'on n'arrête pas de mesures saadi est
j'en reviens pas de vie à tout jamais
travaillé aussi fort depuis des années
[Musique]
bravo pour ta ta passion at monde en
parle hier à merci merci ce téléphone
c'est vraiment une bonne entrevue le
ceclr c'était l'fun qui pour une raison
que j'ignore qui a été frappé de londres
est que tu étais comme louis josé houde
pour lille c'était plus drôle c'est
injuste c'est des petits faits objectifs
politiques rapides
je pense que tu es de bonne humeur parce
que les entrevues qui avait eu un vaste
et avec des politiciens et des surfaces
et plus c'est plus arides ou outils les
policiers ont tendance à un petit partir
une cassette tout s'est tu manges tu
arrivé là en état hyper excité il
acheter comme sur la grosse adrénaline
parce que si c'est tellement horreur que
que les gens ça les intéresse de parler
du tout les questions de développement
pharmaceutique de médicaments petit moi
je t'avais lochte prat et mais là
j'avais hâte d'en parler du fait que je
pense que ça comme transparu dans
quelque chose qui tu parles tu parlais
du donne une période de bouleversements
le puits je pense que il y aurait il y
aura pendant son entrevue à tout le
monde en parle tu devrais m'en ont dit
andrée quand en écoutant ton entrevue
j'ai réalisé qu est ce qui me rendait
aussi bouleversée de la situation
actuelle suis moi il s'était
probablement mon beau mon pessimisme et
montréal
de nature puis l'espèce de feeling de à
chaque fois que j'entends une nouvelle
positive de faire comme je peux sûreté
puis il y aura en direct à bien cerner
le avançons nous posent sur rien parce
qu'en ce moment on est vraiment dans le
flou pitié toutes les espèces de lueur
d'espoir moi je préférerais honnête même
les faire donner plus réalistement que
de me faire dire à wade an d'ici six
mois un vaccin qui guérissent et alors
que tu écoutes un petit peu des experts
comme toi parler puis c'est comme même
si on a un vaccin d'ici six mois on en a
encore pour un bon 3 4 ans avec la copie
de l'outil c'est la ligne entre à être
trop optimiste qui est juste un peu trop
pessimistes qui est juste dans le milieu
c'est super difficile à atteindre cet
équilibre le petit jeu comprendra pas
des mille que abandonné on vit tous
vraiment des du gros stress de la colère
de la frustration nos peurs donc on a
besoin d'affaires positivité mais le
danger est maintenant c'est comme faire
des promesses puis par une somme jugée
idéale aussi les dangers par un peu des
promesses qu après qu on soit pas
capable de tenir facture on a entendu
tout et son contraire depuis le début on
entendu dire à la pandémie
ça va être fini bientôt si justement on
va voir un traitement va voir si on va
voir ce l'immunité collective liant il
va y en avoir une
finalement il n'a pu faire que je me dis
tiens à force de vouloir dire des
enfants trop positives puis après ça on
est obligées de come&stay bac c'est moi
g j comme par un peu de perdre deux
compères de la confiance des gens en
faisant ce avec moi je comme toi je me
sois me faire dire les affaires street
pop up à la version pessimiste ma
version
tout ceci est la version qui est quand
même la peau était très probable
j'ai l'impression que ce que dit madame
j'ai l'impression que là ce que tu dis
de la confiance des gens dont moi j'ai
l'impression que c'est ça qui est le
plus dangereux au sens où on l'a vu
justement on en parle un petit peu avant
de rentrer
un monde on a parlé un petit peu tantôt
mais en disant c'est ça fait à peu près
un mois et demi qu'on parle de début mai
comme étant une espèce de deux piliers
de déblocage que ce soit économique ou
social on arrive en début mais on se
rend compte qu on est loin d'être rendu
à un endroit qui est qui fait du sens
pour ouvrir les que ce soit l'île de
montréal ouvrir les commerces etc etc
terrain pillay arrive un beau week-end
début mai puis parce qu'on a dit parce
que dans notre tête depuis depuis à peu
près deux mois c'est à dire début mes
débuts mais début mai début mais qu'est
ce qui est arrivé en fin de semaine ça a
été le début mai les gens il faisait
beau dehors puis tout le monde est sorti
qu'ils ont et comment c'est fini tu sais
mais c'est loin d'être fini et la courbe
à grimpe encore on est anti pilot six
mois j'ai l'impression qu'en en garde en
l'espèce de de carotte au bout du nez
les gens et quand tu leur enlève la
carotte à la maison pareil
allez chieti j'ai l'impression que c'est
ça qui joue le h et je suis totalement
d'accord puis un autre exemple plus dans
le même style c'est n'était pas en fin
de semaine passée mais l'autre d'avant
si je savais qu'avec annoncé que la
semaine prochaine on va annoncer le plan
des confinement ok le fameux mode
déconfinement bon nous on a dit on est
des amis qui habitent à rosemont dans le
quartier rosemont à montréal qui dans
les ruelles ça alors que tout le monde
il ya plein d'hommes qui ont décidé de
se dé confiné spontanément et en
fauteuil ils ont parlé de déconfinement
nous on était curieux riehl de lamotte
pandémie nous en parle il n'arrête pas
de nous dire que ça arrive au mois de
mai ça va être annoncé la semaine
prochaine et qui ont comme des cons
finis les ruelles fait que d'un coup ben
le monde sorte des ruelles les départs
et il y avait six avaient sauté
c'est un peu ce que ça donne c'est qu'à
un moment donné tu promets tu promets du
premier pilote allemand fait comme ça
arrive 15 d'affaires le sacré de la
frustration sacré de la tension fait que
mais c'est encore l'homme
moi je veux poupe beach et contre la
santé publique c'est la santé publique
je trouve qu'ils font vraiment un super
bon travail sans trop qu'on peut pas les
blâmer de köhler estimé sont un peu au
flash redire comment nature y a personne
qui lit c'est comme ça
je lisais un article qui disait qu'il ya
peu près 50% la population qui pense que
le gouvernement ne cache des
informations
seppi penses tu que dans la situation
actuelle les gouvernements possible des
informations que chamakh qui
transmettent pas qu'il doute on connaît
pas pour justement peut-être type
peut-être que cet optimisme c'est aussi
pour en présenter un scénario trop
pessimiste
de qui on part que les gens soient pas
nier que ce rebelle consacre aux sa
cause et ils vous dansiez trop élevé
qu'en dit on veut ménager un peu le
monde pour justement que pour tout d'un
coup les gens perdaient sport
puisqu'elle est ça soit le cas où je
pense que oui - moi je moi je pense que
oui puisque baisse pas et pas de
théories de conspiration au lieu où il
n'y a pas de complot ou rien c'est que
tige
je me mets dans la peau de la santé
publique le la santé publique qui ont un
rôle où fo qui transmettent la bonne
information mais faut aussi qu'ils s'y
essayent de de prévoir le comportement
des êtres humains c'est si on le voit
dans toutes les toutes les campagnes de
santé publique où il essaie de mettre
des mesures en place
tu es obligé de délais avec un peu
l'irrationalité des gentils et on l'a vu
dans pleine campagne
la fluoration de l'eau potable par
exemple la vaccination même chose c'est
comme si eux doivent dîner avec on a un
certain nombre d'informations mais si on
leur donne 100% de l'information
peut-être que ça va jouer contre nous
tire avec moi j'ai l'impression qu'ils
ôtent bac certaines affaires puis et
puis je pense pas que c'est malhonnête
de leur part je pense que si
objectivement il ya probablement
certaines informations qu'ils disent on
est mieux de paul partagé parce que ce
soit ça va faire paniquer le monde soit
ça va être mal compris c'est fait que je
pense que c'est normal de faire ça moi
je veux pas avoir toute l'information je
m'attends pas à ça je m'attends à voir
des experts compétents c'est seulement
vérité mais pour pour amener peut-être
une nuance à ce admettons l'information
qui pomme divulguer ou divulguer entre
guillemets d'un point de presse
quotidien et cetera et cetera tout ça
puis ces espèces de 2
scénario possible qui sait des experts
qui ont parlé ça on est capable de
retrouver cette information le sais j'en
parlais gens parler d'homme d'autres
fois que quelqu'un qu'on parlait du
délit ou est ce qu'il y avait un expert
de qui avait couvert plusieurs plusieurs
arbres et comme ceux qui possèdent et
estimé qu'ils étaient très pessimiste
par rapport à aux estimée initiale par
exemple aux états unis puis finalement
ça s'est avéré et il ya des gens qui
font des scénarios qu'on est capable de
trouver tpiy je pense que ce que toi tu
te faisais à un sculpteur frayeur à tout
le monde en parle c'est à dire dire hey
on va se calmer sur le vaccin
c'est une information selon dd des
expériences jeu bien selon dd des
données qui ont été assemblés dans
l'histoire de qu'est ce que ça peut
avoir l'air un vaccin qui en comprend
temps de prendre cette information là on
peut l'avoir fait moi mettons la nuance
que j'aimerais c'est paul le
gouvernement cache des informations
c'est de plus essayer de garder ceux du
côté positif nous mettons du truc
je suis totalement d'accord ils gardent
prenons un exemple précis parce que il
ya les gens n'ayant eu de ce qu'est
exactement ce que tu décris le sait
quand ça fait quoi ça fait deux trois
semaines notre seul camion dit en fait
tous les journalistes tous les
journalistes demandaient d'avoir accès
aux prévisions 1
il voulait avoir là il voulait savoir où
est-ce qu'on était rendu sur la courbe
donc les gars étaient pas de se faire
gossip a tout les jours la santé
publique j'en sors télécom sortez les
prévisions on veut savoir on est où dans
coupe qu'est ce qui s'en vient qu'est-ce
que 100 me pour les prochaines semaines
la bla bla puis au début on sentait très
clairement que la santé publique il n'y
avait pas envie de les partager les
s'était en fait c'est pas la coupe
d'italie scénario le teaser c'est un
genou les scénarios bon il y avait plein
courbe le scénario négatif et
océanopolis exactement fait que moi moi
mon impression c'est que je sentais que
y'avait pas là il voulait pas la
partager cette information là je pense
pas parce qu'il voulait cacher des
enfants je pense pas que c'est pour ça
je pense que c'est que ils se disent
probablement mais sans la présence des
scénarios mixer scénario là se
matérialisent politicus et l'on va se
faire on va se voir beach et qu'est ce
qui s'est passé exactement ce qui s'est
passé parce que dame et ont sorti les
scénarios puis dès les premiers jours
après le monde comme
là on a remarqué qu'il y avait telle
affaire là on n'est pas le yacht à la
fin mais ça marche pas c'est comme si le
monde n'est jamais content oui tu leur
donnes les scénarios le ibis ya le
scénario tu leur donnes pas un scénario
ils disent qu'on leur cache des choses
suspectes
je suis d'accord avec toi t'y je pense
que on peut la voir quelqu'un aurait pu
faire toutes ces recherches par lui-même
mais la vaste majorité des jeunes la
fraude c'est quand ça nous intéresse on
l'a fait je les besoins sait aussi que
c'est extrêmement difficile avec les
informations qu'on en ce moment de faire
des projections des modèles qui sont
sont accueillis et le pis j'ai écouté un
podcast les podcasts devenir degrasse
tyson qui avaient en commun éviter
qu'ils disaient c'est à ce moment il ya
tellement de scientifiques un des petits
de le groupe indépendant qui font des
projections qui sont tellement différent
parce que les données qui entrent dans
leurs modèles sont différentes c'est si
tu penses ci se prend pour acquis comme
étant une personne en moyenne quelques
grenades et russes vont infecter deux
autres personnes mais lopez 5
ça donne des résultats sont complètement
différents quand tu files annales la
méta-analyse toutes les projections là
ça donne que pratiquement du bruit parce
que parce qu'il n'y a pas de consensus
exactement sur les données exactes cefac
est présent sur quoi les politiciens se
baser sur qui écoute et là dedans c'est
excessivement difficile à savoir
totalement bien un autre bon exemple de
tous et les fameux ar 0 c'est le le ska
p or not known as anglais c'est le taux
de reproduction du virus donc c'est un
chiffre qui est souvent minute quand on
parle de pandémie maintenant les films
d'écouter des films de pandémie de
grippe à tout en 2h02 ceci à kehl à
quelle vitesse normale le virus va se
répandre et autrement dit une personne
infectée à vannes en infecter combien
c'est donc là au début on nous disait
bon mais leur héroïque et imputant leur
m'emmener en équipe 0 à arles parce
qu'il était le pays qui ont dit que leur
héros était telle chose qu'il y avait du
monde mais comme anxieux parce que on
n'avait pas toutes les mêmes versions
10h01 un moment donné le yankee les
experts qui ont fait et en patience
parce que le concept de taux de
reproduction le bain il sera pas le même
non seulement dans tout les pays parce
que y est dépendant des mesures comprend
pour contrer le virus l'heure zéro le
taux de reproduction sera pas le même
avec des mesures de confinement il sera
pas le même avec la distanciation social
physique selon certaines réalités
géographiques très vexé comme si c est
comme deux
être trop de données ça fait en sorte
qu'un moment donné bas les gens y vont
tétreault de donner 100 des données
difficiles à comprendre belle tu vas
voir tu sortes d'interprétations pis si
des fois ça peut générer plus d'anxiété
codé maison comprend pour pour traiter
le virus mais aussi b pour empêcher le
virus de se reproduire mais aussi des
mesures en fait comment qu'on mesure le
virus c'est parce que si oui qui compile
les données la même façon que tout le
monde qu'elle a même été des régimes
rigueur sur les causes justes au québec
les coques sont confirmées je dirai
combien de coquilles et quelqu'un comme
un virus mais qui n'ont pas été
confirmées parce qu'il parlait pts à
l'épreuve de tests quoique ce soit qui
restait sur quatre est exact il veille
aussi à premièrement tilala la méthode
de comptabilisation des dicos et pas
partout pareil pile en ce moment il y
avait beaucoup de questionnements savoir
par exemple ce que la chine aurait comme
va donner vraiment les bronchites
on s'entend s'il ya des endroits où que
délibérément lyon fossé où ils ont mal
présenté les données dans un objectif
était en fait de demande s'ils ont agi
de façon malhonnête mais faut qu'on le
sache puis j'espère qu'il va y avoir des
conséquences à son hit largement j je
suis pas du tout un support de comme
mener le monde en erreur le tri mais
comme au québec en ce moment c'est ce
tir comme j'écoutais le point de presse
je savais qu'on se parle qui déjeunent
j'entendais journal excusé le comme vous
quand vous avez compté quelque chose
pour toyota faire telle chose dont on
comprend plus rien puis comme garde
boeuf s'est amené en plus obstinée
longtemps sur les chiffes même en autant
qu'on n'a pas l'impression qu'on nous
mène en bateau délibérément 6 juin
audrey comme le sait si des fois je
trouve qu'on exagère peut-être un petit
peu là dessus je lisais un article je
pense dans la presse qui l'article
intitulé les gérants d'estrade entendu
que renault virus quelque chose qui
ressemblait à ça je me rappelle plus
exactement de ceux de l'arctique mais
sommes tous que le journaliste puis
c'est malheureux encore une fois
j'oublie son nom faudrait que j'avais
mieux mais sur sa portée de main mais le
journaliste expliquait que dans
n'importe quelle situation qui ont
autant d'inconnues que en ce moment on
peut pas traiter de on peut
à prendre des décisions selon le temps -
et que ce jour faut toujours être sur le
temps présent parce que tellement de
nouvelles informations ont peut pas
comme en ce moment nous mettons le dôme
tu dis qu'ils reportaient l'ouverture
des entreprises à montréal d'une semaine
tu peux pas être fâché parce que bleu
bleu une semaine nous avait dit qu'il
s'arrête une semaine plus tôt parce
qu'elle est statique ont changé les
données ont changé ça évolue constamment
puis si on se forge du changement des
ddd du processus de déconfinement ou du
retour à la normalité
on s'en sortira jamais elle parce que
parce que de de l'inconnu on va en avoir
encore pour plusieurs années par rapport
à ce qui fait que j'imagine qu'il faut
collectivement changer notre mindset
puis être prêt à accepter le temps que
ça va prendre ces mêmes aussi frustrant
que ça peut être mais c'est difficile
parce la whip it on peut on a le droit
d'être fauché ci est de la pure
incompétence t aux états unis si on
regarde la façon que cette énergie se
sont pris ben trop tard il était dans le
haut débit était carrément dans le déni
alisme du virus c'est ça c'est ceci
c'est horrible pays seul léger qui sont
fâchés aux états unis de tuer et ont
raison ici et ici on est dans une
situation comme si je prends maintenant
le québec lé si le québec j'ai
l'impression qu'on était quand même très
proactifs on a suivi les données
probantes si on était dans les pays très
des très progressiste très très petit et
beaucoup d'initiatives par rapport aux
pays dans le monde qui se prenait bien
effective à un moment donné après si on
peut se positionner sur des détails le
mais la vérité c'est que est ce qu'on
est et ce qu'on gère bien la pandémie en
ce moment mais on va le savoir après la
pandémie
c'est un peu frustrant de se dire ça
mais c'est comme si toute les harengs
qu'on a fait on va les savoirs par après
mais la situation qu'on vit en ce moment
on n'a jamais vécu seul de ne nous dit à
nous la lentille un moment donné et ben
oui on va apprendre de cette pandémie
l'heure on espère qu en europe à une
autre mais mais dans un sens ici tout ce
qu'on vit en ce moment la pandémie
pillage parler du développement de
médicaments de vaccins qui est comme
pris tu prend quelque chose qui se fait
sur 15 à 25 ans je le fais en deux ans
jamais fait un enfant dans man c'est sûr
qu'on va faire des gaffes flottille et
on le saura pas pendant qu'on est en
train de faire des gaffes
puis le développement justement d'aider
dix vaccins est-ce que y des étapes
déontologiques qui sont sautés est ce
qu'il ya des des processus d'aidé
fastrack admettons que qui sont alloués
pour cause de pandémie mondiale
ouais c'est sûr que dans le
développement d'un vaccin spécifiquement
le processus qui est en mode très
accéléré
comment ce qu'ils font ce bain la
plupart des compagnies qui font ce
moment c'est qu'ils vont faire toutes
les étapes de développement parallèle
donc normalement vaccin tu voi étudié en
laboratoire ensuite chez des animaux
ensuite chez des humains des études de
plus en plus grande chez les humains
puis à la fin aussi une étape du support
important à laquelle on pense pas
souvent mais c'est que il faut le
fabriquer le vaccin en quantité massive
de vaccins c'est un vaccin c'est pas de
mélange et 3,4 pour l'ensemble comme un
médicament que tu avales en poudre en
arsenic non exactement c'est pas mal
plus compliqué que ça c'est si ça se
fait dans des grosses incubateur avec du
matériel vivant c'est hautement
imprévisible donc c'est ce que tu sois
capable de faire sandoz dans son labo
pour des tests mais que le jour où tu
décides on va passer à un million ça
marche pull sasakawa complètement le
processus ne serait il pas en anglais le
fait que toutes ces étapes là ce moment
sont fait tout en parallèle fait la
compagnie va faire à la fois des études
animales humaines et en même temps de la
fabrication dans l'espoir que leur
vaccin est pas une chose qui est
vraiment importante à savoir aussi par
rapport aux vaccins
c'est peut-être compris de suite if mais
c'est que contrairement aux médicaments
un vaccin c'est très facile à faire je
donne un exemple au mois de janvier
yann compagnie aux états unis qui
avaient déjà un vaccin au mois de
janvier les salariés ça leur avait pris
trois heures à les mettre sur papier qui
ensuite quoi une coupe de jours de
semaines à le faire dans leurs labos ok
c'est fou hein jamais isolé le virus
puis y avait soit isolé le virus ou
aujourd'hui on n'est même plus obligé de
faire sans à passer en notes il est
l'historique mais les vaccins se tait on
prend le virus on le met soient vivants
ou inactive et où on met un morceau de
la de là
actuelle du virus aujourd'hui à des
méthodes encore plus fois qu'excellent
c'est quand même tu peux prendre juste
un petit bout du code génétique du virus
pile corps va penser que c'est sûr ils
l'ont design et sans pas été compliqué
puis en on fait puis ça il y avait un
vaccin mais là ce stade le le vaccin
n'est pas hypothéqué
premièrement donc on sait pas s'il est
efficace on ne sait pas s'il est
sécuritaire puis loin des tomes d'être
fabriqué puis tester l'efficacité d'un
vaccin c'est ricky parce que mettons un
médicament même temps un médicament qui
abaisse la pression artérielle des
tonnes de médicaments pour la pression
de la personne
ben si ça marche un vaccin de bus et
prévenir une maladie que la personne
n'aurait peut-être pas attraper de toute
façon vannerie tu peux pas le résultat
ça prend du temps avec ses valises les
dernières études les toutes dernières
études de vaccins à la fin du
développement
je sais ça prend des années qu'il a
fallu fabrication le où tu skies jusqu'à
des millions de doses baisse à 6,7
milliards de baisse cela normalement ça
prend aussi des années donc si je lisais
palafittes je peux aussi vous connaissez
pour le fitr c'est un des top indé dick
king monde mondiaux de la vaccination
lui-même y ont inventé un vaccin vaccin
contre le rotavirus cette saloperie 26
ans développé son vaccin contre le
rotavirus 26 ans qu'en ce moment on nous
dit qu'on va avoir un vaccin dans 12 à
18 mois
tiens si ce n'est vous que tirer c'est
un espèce de course de foule
j'entendais que le record du monde pour
la découverte du virus qu'un vaccin qui
était sur le marché possible c'est la
fois que ça a été fait le plus vite
s'arrêter 4 1 je me rappelle pas citer
pourquoi le mais c'est celle a donné que
j'avais entendu les imagine ce le plus
vite la différence peut-être en ce
moment c'est que y'a plein combat où
tout le monde travaille sur la même
affaire
c'est pour ça qu'il ya plein de choses
qui bougent parce que toutes les équipes
de recherche travaille sur la même chose
est ce que donne collaboration globale
ça dépend ce que tu entends par
collaboration aux bascules la communauté
scientifique à la base collabore
toujours dans la mesure où quand on
publie des travaux de recherche
ben c'est pour vous c'est pour donner
accès à l'ensemble la communauté
scientifique
ceci étant dit un laboratoire développe
son vaccin
ils vont quand même essayer de mener
leurs vaccins actuels pour l'instant
mine d'or la compagnie qui veut réussir
à découvrir ou avoir un vaste un vaccin
efficace peut être capable de le sceller
à une échelle planétaire ça va être ça
va être des milliards et des milliards
de dollars de tous les gouvernements qui
doit avoir un ange économiques énormes
maintenant y'a s'améliore pas je
souhaite élargir financiers en raison de
ces plaques
je sais je sais que c'est là qu'on
n'aime pas sa pensée à sanaa mais c'est
la compagnie qui va faire un vaccin a
beau vouloir qui rentrait dans son
argent à un repli de 1 probablement
aussi en profiter mais mais il ya plus
que ça en fait parce que en ce moment
une centaine de vaccins différents qui
sont en développement
une centaine chasser différentes
d'habitude d'étudier tantôt que le
record de 4,1 mais y'a jamais sans
vaccin qui sont développés pour une
infection
donc c'est sûr que la daille en une
coupe qui vont allumer plus vite que
d'autres là dedans il y en a assez des
compagnies en os x et d'élaborer des
labo indépendant qui est qui une chose
qui est aussi problématique c'est tout
les enjeux géopolitiques autour de ce
don est exemple il ya un dédit grands
fabricants de vaccins en inde
ils ont annoncé que si eux ils trouvent
un vaccin ils gardent pour eux ouais
donc ils l'ont déjà dit le nous on va
vacciner les gens en inde avant de le
donner à qui que ce soit mais que si
c'est eux qui trouvent ce qu'ils font je
pense qu'on en a ils sont en dessous
quelque chose comme un point qui
améliore le fait que s'y trouvent ainsi
font un vaccin qui marche qui est
efficace parce qu'ils ont un milliard de
doses mais sans lui mais le vaccin il
sortira jamais de linde y avait un
laboratoire aussi à en allemagne c'est
dans un podcast des délits qui hélas
scientifique un second tour le quitte et
ceux qui sont fait offrir un milliard de
dollars par les etats unis pour acheter
en fait le laboratoire pour avoir un nom
en avant sur le vaccin fac évidemment
quel pays qui va détenir les remèdes en
premier vous
utilisée pour lui pis
puis après c'est qu'il va avoir accès à
son premier hit i est ce que que les
pays plus pauvres vont avoir un dernier
est ce que ça crie ça d'inégal type
questions qui sont vraiment dans un
monde idéal on n'est pas dans un monde
est armé d'un mondial on penserait pas
comme ça on penserait pas un tel pays
fait le vaccin c'est lui qui l'a on
devrait penser en termes de qui en a le
plus besoin en ce moment
quand il a crevé 19 faut pas oublier le
que ya plus que 80 % des gens qui
attrapent l'infection qui ont des
symptômes légers qui vont bien s'en
sortir avec ces gens là sont pas
prioritaires ont des vrais vacciner en
priorité les personnes qui sont
vulnérables qui est donc les personnes
âgées les personnes qui ont des maladies
chroniques etc
s'il y en a partout sur la planète donc
logiquement donc on prend l'exemple de
l'humble au jeu pour pitcher contre
l'inde où il met donc lines est bon si
on trouve un vaccin qui confère un
milliard de doses
on devrait distribuer le milliard de
doses dans tout les pays en vaccinant
les personnes prioritaires chaque pays
pourrait avoir 6 2 puis à livres les
plus prioritaires la vérité s'exprime ça
va fonctionner si on est surtout dans
une période comme de pandémie c'est un
peu comme une guerre
c'est dans le fond quand tu es dans une
guerre dieu du protectionnisme c'est les
pays vont être convoqués ne faut pas que
j'en donne trop à l'autre parce que moi
si je suis dans la merde après que je
vais faire ici même au québec on se dit
baye leur faudrait qu'on commence à
penser utile et masques des blues les
visières vrai qu'on soit capable de
produire nous mêmes si c'est pas c'est
pas mal on ait nécessairement de faire
ça c'est une question de se dire crime
si on n'est pas autosuffisants bain qui
qui nous dit que maintenant on va pas se
faire
sauf à bachs d'habitants ce qui est une
possibilité que le vaccin si on le
trouve soit efficace pendant peut-être
un an
quand j'ai su que le virus ya une
mutation qui reviennent dessus une autre
forme d' apprécier de tous leurs
médicaments nous aux vaccins sont rompus
bon bah oui oui ça se peut dans l'absolu
mais aussi encore lassé des questions
que ces épis moche si georges est pas
une expertise en immunologie ou en
virologie le vraiment pas mais titi
poserait cette question là à 10 explique
probablement répondre et c'est à ce
stade si on le sait pas encore c'est
dans mesure où est ce que le vaccin est
ce que le virus pourrait muter et puis
que tout d'un coup tout ce qu'ont
développé marche plus bas en théorie ça
se pourrait
mais déjà des recherches dans ce sens le
limitation en lien avec le virus tout ça
c'est étudié donc tout ça doit être tenu
en compte forcément dans le
développement des mails witty dans
l'absolu c'est ici c'est possible c'est
comme les histoires de deuxième pays qui
va savoir un deuxième pic
ça va devenir une infection qui
saisonnières d'ici comme lala com
l'influenza tse qui vient qui apparaît
peut-être c'est plate mais c'est la
réponse est potable
au début on parlait d' immunité
collective et on disait qu'ils parlement
que se situe la trappe pour la marque
soit immunisée parce que beaucoup de
virus fonctionne comme ça après sony
c'est pour prouver on ne sait peut-être
que le virus ou si vous tombez en
dormance comme un but le vih
mais est-ce que contrairement à ce que
ce que la région avancer ce niveau la
pièce qu'on peut quand même assumé que
comme la plupart des virus fonctionne
comme ça il faut que tu le on devrait
agir comme si c'était le cas ou non
encore l'autiste une question que moi
c'est pas dans mon champ expertise fait
que je pourrais pas répondre quelque
chose de super précis mais ces thèmes de
manière générale ce que je peux dire
c'est que si ça s'appelait l'esprit de
croire que quand étaient infectés quand
un certain type d'infection sur vos
développer des anticorps
si tu développes les anticorps après tu
devrais être protégé contre la maladie
la vérité c'est que ça se produit pas
tout le temps il ya certaines il ya
certains types d'infections que le
système immunitaire réagit de façon
super forte mais il faut pas avoir une
production d'anticorps à long terme ou à
l inverse il n'y a pas de production
d'entretien c'est pas c'est pas tout à
la même affaire finalement il dans le
cas de la
dans le cas de la côte 19 je pense que
c'est les coronavirus on n'est pas
habitué à sol s'est dit virus que l'on
connaît pas tant que ce fait je pense
qu'au début on a comme on disait
beaucoup présenté cette infection comme
un genre de grippe
un genre d'influencé avec on pense à la
grippe les influenceurs on le sait qu'on
développe des anticorps mais encore là
on les développe à long terme
j'ai fini mom de grippe à ta des grippes
des rhumes possiblement des grippes
mais je penserais pas
tu es tu sûr d'être sûr parce qu'une
grippe l'on s'entende juste pour être
clair la grippe le sait que des
désordres pana ouais c'est ça parce que
la grippe l'influenza c'est la fiève
fièvre douleurs musculaires fatigue
en gros c'est ça les symptômes sur une
partie de moi même tes poches en sus
sérieux et intense moi j'en ai eu deux
grippes dans ma vie qui est des fois je
pensais que j'allais mourir les deux
fois l' un des gros rhume mais parce que
je me suis je fais pas de test pour ce
mais est ce que est ce que c'est
possible dans notre appel à toutes les
saisons une grippe
oui oui c'est possible parce que
justement on développe pas une immunité
à long terme
l'immunité votre durée pendant mettons
en fait on le sait pas précisément puis
aussi la france et que le taux de
mutation de l'influencé très élevé donc
à chaque année c'est pas les mêmes
souches qui circulent donc c'est
peut-être que tu peux conserver son
immunité pour plus qu'un en mai
mais même là tu peux été infecté par une
autre souche et tout ça donc est-ce que
ça va devenir la même chose pour la
copie de 19
on s'est entendu qu'on espère que non là
parce que c'est un mécha bordel en ce
moment puis c'est pas beau temps en
temps cette affaire de memensigh petit
jeu je sais pas quel c'est ça c'est
tellement dur de c'est tellement dur de
s'imaginer qu'est-ce que savoir être et
pis moi quand je pense hier j'avais
justement si j'ai appelé mon papillon
puis on ne parlait depuis un bon bout
depuis on essaie d'imaginer c'est la
suite des choses qui me moi je voyais
tellement pas bien commun je donne
l'exemple du festival d'été de québec
mettons moi je voyais pas comment
l'année prochaine on a un festival d'été
de québec
je voyais pas comment dans le prochain
cycle de 12 mois
on a des salles de spectacles parce que
pour être capables de faire ce métier de
commun en ce moment ça se passe puis
pour être capable de faire sur faudrait
prendre la décision collective de dire
vous avez en autriche en disant rester
chez vous ou risquer de mourir s'il
faudrait qu'on ferait qu'en tant que
société on se dise si on veut ré ouvrir
comme c'était qu'on se dise ok ben les
années restez chez vous parce que parce
qu'une zone rouge la société
mais j'ai l'impression que j'imaginais
ça puis je me disais avec toutes les
informations qu'on a pu avec le fait que
je dire si le mans nîmes aura centaine
par jour au québec la centaine par jour
ça diminue pas moi je me disais je
voyais ça puis je me dis comment est ce
qu'on peut imaginer
retournez dans un regroupement de
personnes dans les prochains 12 mois
puis après seule haute idée qui m'est
venue quand parle en mon père c'était de
dire va falloir va falloir vivre dans un
nouveau monde pour les pour les
prochaines années
offre hors que notre réalité devienne
quelque chose de complètement différente
parce que je ne vois pas je vois pas
comment un bar sold out sur saint denis
va pouvoir exister dans les prochains 12
mois les je le vois juste pas en direct
peut-être que c'est moi qui ai vraiment
pessimiste mais on dirait que pour moi
la solution c'est de dire on est dans
une nouvelle réalité en ce moment et je
pense je pense que la vision que tu
présentes le sais c'est pas mal si c'est
en fait c'est là c'est la llc ce qui
s'en vient par défaut le stadio
présentement au regard de ceux à qui on
venait en vois pas d'autre solution
encore le garde 12 heures ça fait
combien de temps qu'on est là dedans la
saf et savent depuis le 12 mars ça fait
même pas deux mois encore effective
qu'est ce que ça va être au mois de
septembre
on le sait pas mais c'est sûr qu'elles
sont obligées d'en admettre
admettons qu'on veut essayer d'être
optimiste et j'ai de la misère à voir
quels sont les avenues parce que telle
et mettons l'avenue la plus optimiste
depuis aucun signe que c'est le cas
parce que le virus est au brésil bien en
australie c'est de dire que l'été va
cela qu'est ce mais aucun signe que ça
fait ce il ya aucun signe avant coureur
que con
un médicament qui fonctionne bien dans
les prochains les prochains 12 mois de
c'est moi c'est sûr comme ça je le vois
qu'on dirait que plus je pense plus je
me dis il faut que je me fasse à l'idée
de ces que confidences d'un monde
différent
ben écoute ce que tu décris l'heure
c'est en gros c'est le sait la pensée
réaliste le stade i et espérer le
meilleur
mais reconnaître que le scénario idéal
qu'on en a peut-être ils vont
probablement pas se produire et que
d'essayer de d'envisager sais quoi qui
pourrait se produire si c'est le cas
comment je dois vivre avec ça est ce que
tu dis c'est ok là j'aurai plus de ce
festival
j'irai plus d'un restaurant plus de bord
ok avec ça va être quoi ma vie tu sais
qu'ils soient je pense que c'est la
bonne attitude c'est ce qu'il faut qu'on
fasse en ce moment ce qui touche un
point que ça m'a fait ça m'a allumé une
lumière de parler on n'aura pas de
médicaments seuls certains je sais pas
si je peux dire que c'est une gaffe mais
c'est quelque chose qui a été mal
compris peut-être ce que je pense qu'il
ya beaucoup de gens qui ont eu qui sont
restés avec l'impression qu'ils ont on
développerait peut-être un médicament
qu'ont pris donné à tout le monde
puis que ce médicament là pourraient
faire en sorte qu' il est tellement été
il prévient tellement bien la maladie
qu'on pourrait recommencer à vivre notre
vie normalement en attendant le vaccin
la vérité sexuelle si c est ça
relèverait du miracle de proue de
pouvoir trouver un médicament comme ça
les médicaments qu'on développe en ce
moment le sait pour le monde qui sont en
train de mourir à l'hôpital
c'est pas pour donner à monsieur madame
tout le monde vous moi on n'est vraiment
pas la leçon ça arrivera probablement
pas factice châssis d'accord avec toi
que moi non plus en ce moment là j'en
vois pas de joie pas d'autre issue que
de poursuivre l'espèce de distanciation
puis tout ce qu'ils rassemblements ou
contactez visent des proches
moi je non plus je le vois pas mais
quand même on est quand même jusqu'au
deuxième mode d'une crise qui connaît
mon nouvel c'est vraiment dur de dire
dans un air ça va ressembler à quoi je
pense la personne ne sait vraiment pis
j'imagine que sicile la théorie de l'une
des collective est vrai bien et puis les
gens qu'ils l'ont eu
- le virus peut se propager d'une
personne à l'autre pierre manetti la
réalité c'est aussi que cette jeunesse
une crise qui est grave c'est un virus
qui est dangereux mais n'empêche que
l'âme
grande grand majorité des gens qui la
trappe en europe où le tpiy ils vont
avoir des symptômes
parfois c'est le jury le juste un mois
moi c'est ma manche en isolement complet
parce que j'avais un symptôme qui je me
suis dit c'est pas ta dessus j'ai parlé
au médecin au téléphone c'est que des
données rendez-vous téléphonique et
qu'un médecin
j'ai dit à angela mal de gorge c'est pas
mal tout ce que j'ai eu des petites
entités jeunes s'est peut-être dit ça
parce que ça peut être seulement ce ton
symptômes donc on prend pour acquis que
c'est ce dont kiesel touaffeck très bon
ok mais mais bref c'est ce type ici on
prend pour acquis justement aussi tous
les gens qui aiment qu'ils l'ont mais
quiconque le cpo letombe mortalité de
cette maladie le calme à ses bottés plus
que d'autres mais quand même assez beau
somme toute mais très élevés pour
certaines personnes généralement âgées
après ce le coup on fait avec ce coût à
payer mettons de déconfinement puis
d'immunité collective j'ai l'impression
qu'ils tellement élevé pour pour deux
pour relancer l'économie
econocom pas choix j'ai l'impression
parce que si on sort jamais le drame
année on va le poignet un jour ou
l'autre mais son sort jamais en fait
juste retardé dans le fond je pense que
le but du confinement c'était juste un
peu tout le monde le poignet en même
temps c'est ce que dit estimé au début
c'étaient les intimes est sorti dix ans
38 10 % des québécois vont avoir le
chrono virus et non le fond le
confinement c'est juste que au lieu
qu'elles se dire on ne peut tout en même
temps parce que c'est quand même ultra
quand même très contagieux on traverse
total et en même temps puis on manque de
ressources mais on étale son allonge un
petit peu ça faire le met bien c'est sûr
mais je pense que ça reviendra du
helmand on va continuer le pony -
continue pogné d'amener leur panier de
moins en moins je serai plus en plus de
monde pour l'avoir eu mal mais ils
coûtent si c'était assez totalement
raison là parce que le confinement à
l'origine c'était pour aplatir la courbe
c'est donc l'idée qu' il faut pas
saturer le système de santé il faut pas
dépasser les capacités du système de
santé
donc on a imaginé le pire scénario on
s'est dit qu'est ce qui se passe et les
hôpitaux sont remplis les soins
intensifs
epub
de la mortalité en masse tout ça c'est
parce que ces produits parce que on a
mis en place les mesures de confinement
extérieur donc là c'est cool mais comme
tu dis combien de temps ça gère un
confinement comme ça j'en ai aucune idée
il tient un moment donné les
conséquences négatives du confinement si
seul est une autre affaire ça revient
plus à ce qu'on dit tantôt c'est que en
santé publique et en n'importe quelle
intervention constructeur risque versus
bénéficie t fait commander c'est quand
même la mesure qu'on met en place c'est
quoi c'est quoi le bienfait qu'on en
retire versus le risque donc le
confinement au départ c'était ce qu'il
fallait faire seul et bien fait dépasser
les risques de façon majeure mais le
plus on avance plus ce ratio le commence
à devenir de même parce que là le monde
commence à virer fou le mener le monde
travaille plus il ya des faillites avec
leur maman donné ça va devenir moins ok
bah le bouclier ya du risque du
confinement et du réseau trappe et la
maladie si on sera plus la balance est
en évolution aussi l'exact qui on parle
de type qu'il faudrait jamais mettre
l'économie avant la vie humaine cherche
comme le monde accorde ex sauf que socke
et les coûts de la santé premièrement
besoins de l'économie pour veiller visé
pour avoir les ressources pour pouvoir
traiter soigner les gens faut qu'ils
aient un minimum d'argent qui rentre
dans les coffres de l'état
sinon sinon ça fonctionne juste plus
deuxièmement aussi des gens qui
souffrent une manière différente de la
coved 19 pas de la maladie elle-même et
des répercussions économiques si si je
peut plus nourrir ma famille j'étais il
ya des gens qui vont mourir du kavé 19
sans jamais l'avoir attrapé des dommage
collatéral
c'est pour ça qu'on peut pas non plus m
la santé puis les coronavirus comme
valeur suprême puis 2-2 tout relayé en
dessous de ça parce qu'il est justement
le confinement des progrès santé mentale
les premiers konami qu'il faudrait
traiter rock il faut aussi prendre en
compte dans l'équation whip it here des
fois on entend cela on met l'économie
avant la santé mais je suis d'accord
avec toi l'espagne serait de mettre
l'économie en premier mais c'est que la
la la la santé d'une société en général
c'est va cela comme concept le donc titi
je pense que piper h 16 ça rejoint ce
que tu disais tantôt des eti les bars
les restaurants les lire
les les festivals c'est la vérité c'est
que je pense que l'idéal serait qu'on
retourne à une vie comme normal peu semi
normal mais que toutes les choses non
essentiels qui obligent des
rapprochements avec son sang parle c'est
parce qu'on le sentait en hip-hop - moi
j'adore ça allait à heavy mtl l'été mais
je peux vivre ça pendant deux trois ans
il faut je vais pas mourir mais la
culture moi je trouve que c'est
essentiel by van on est très mal très
mal placé pour très mal placé pour
parler contre la culture le team et je
n'ai pas un peu de ça dans un sens mais
maitient festival par exemple si à ma
mission peut pas ou peu paul fait que
fait que c'est ce qui va être top le
sava etre de manitou de retourner à la
vie la plus normale possible mais en
n'acceptant que certaines activités
auront peut-être pas lieu
pitié moi je suis d'accord avec ce que
vous disiez par rapport aux dommages
collatéraux t'aimer problème économique
c'est bad c'est pas cool problèmes de
santé mentale c'est pas cool
la mort c'est vraiment beaucoup c'est
juste que ça ne plus l'argent si
l'économie va tellement mal connaître
l'argent pour pour traiter les malades
lawman traiter quelqu'un qui arrive à
l'hôpital parce qu'ils aient besoin
d'une chirurgie cardiaque qu'on n'a pas
les ressources pour lui donner sa
partenaire pour mourir ou city méthyle
je veux dire l'économie
somme toute est pas complètement arrêté
les entreprises trouvent des façons de
continuer les tipis ce gpo permettons
que justement le archambault avec pignon
sur rue y va pouvoir ré ouvrir tpiy
l'économie comme on comme on l'entend je
voudrais pas complètement sûr pose qu'on
voudrait ouvrir les régions le monde
vont vouloir aller en gaspésie était le
moment vont continuer à faire rouler
l'économie mais j'ai vraiment
l'impression que pendant un bout tout ce
qui est rapprochement ça ça va être un
passé parce que le risque doit être trop
grande
c'est mettons la en ce moment sexy non
sinon pour mettons les personnes âgées
en outre 80 ans qui leur reste trois
quatre ans maintenant le devis ben ils
vont passer ses trois quatre ans là en
confinement complet
et jusqu'à temps de mourir entouré de
personnes
ces jeux moi j'ai l'impression que si
cette option là kiki que moi j'envisage
vraiment mal de dire on veut juste dire
aux gens qui ont un oeil du monde de
l'été du monde de 75 comme encore super
en forme le thé sauf que s'ils attrapent
ceux qui ont un taux de mortalité de
chez pas combien de pour ça n'est pas
possible chez moi j'ai l'impression que
ce risque là est beaucoup trop coûteuse
c'est un peu ça que moi j'envisage
puisque je me dis créé mais on en a pour
un bouton nommé au début de la pandémie
le les états unis avaient un peu la
proche de bombes et là on va on va pas
capoter avec ça on va pas tout remettre
suppose tout ça pis oui peut-être que
des gens qui sont plus à risque mais et
si c'était plus des personnages et audi
qui minimisait beaucoup les associations
mais quand le monde sait bien mourir
tout d'un coup l'opinion populaire
allait chuter le moment donné c'est
comme si on aime tout ceci s'imagine
dans nos têtes on va dire qu'ici c'est
un dur prix à payer mais il ya des gens
qui vont mourir mais le jour où ça
commence à arriver par contre là d'un
coup le saviez nous confronter dans nos
valeurs de ces faits que tu es moche je
pense aussi que si on sera jamais
capable d'accepter éthiquement
moralement de la mortalité sans candidat
et coûtent aussi csu et éviter peut être
évité exactement
mais c'est la preuve le martèle t ai
tant qu'à moi il peut juste cause et par
l'économie russe en tant que tel
ben oui mais causer c'est la mortalité
la grand majorité c'est d'un sachet
celle des c'est là que ça se passe
pis parce que je dire des ressources
pied comment comment ces structures et
je dois les enfants entassés les autres
les autres adam qui généraient pas des
conditions de vie reading seppi ita que
seul problème si on avait ces dalles et
justes dans les résidences pour
personnes âgées en général ça va quand
même vraiment mieux c'est le même genre
de monde le fait que je pense que
problème c'est aussi le ch et 70 ans
moi j'ai appris quelque chose que je
connais tu mens je mettais jamais posé
cette question là mais c'est pour tous
les pays
c'est pas dans toutes les cultures où on
met les personnes d'industrie marges
dans des grosses bâtisses plutôt qu'il
ya des endroits où ses potes dans la
culture de faire ça ils l'ont pas ce
problème relatif est classé comme ab
intéressante ici il ya un autre modèle
c'est un autre sujet là mais je sais que
je vais pas peut-être une grosse
parenthèse mais tant il ya une réflexion
à ce moment qu'est ce qu'on peut
améliorer puis on se rend compte de
plein de problèmes puis après ça on va
faire des choses comme on se dit
justement les personnes des personnes
âgées dit sue correcte des maîtres dans
des places comme sort de refaire des
plus de centres plus des maisons plus
abordables à sa voiture vraiment se
traduire après un changement réel je le
sais pas mais c'est une problématique
qui apparemment qui n'existent pas
partout dans le monde je trouve ça
vraiment intéressant
il faudrait qu'elle soit posée sur
comment qu'on commet contre elle nous a
dit comment qu'on voit là la fin une
fille totalement
moi j'ai travaillé quand j'étais
étudiant en fait moi j'ai eu une seule
job d'étudiant dans ma vie ok parce que
je l'aimais tellement que j'ai jamais
quitté j'ai commencé à 16 ans
travaillait comme préposé aux
bénéficiaires dans un an fait dans un
hôpital qui était aussi un ch et celle
des c'était des gens qui souffrait de
démence dont alzheimer démence
vasculaire des choses comme ça donc des
personnes vraiment le comme très
hypothétique souvent ils sont plus
vraiment nécessairement conscients de
tout ce qui se passe plutôt surpris j'ai
travaillé pendant six ans avec ces
personnes-là de seppi
écoute c'est l'enfer le pied mais en
même temps si je faisais mon travail
avec eux puis on a du fun puis on essaie
de leur offrir un peu de bonheur
peu importe de quoi y ont besoin d'ici
on essaie vraiment fort mais c'est dit
c'est dit c'est dit signifie qu'ils sont
vraiment pas cool
moi ça me revient ça me revient soulager
des flashbacks de cette époque là où je
donnais débat et puis que je ne
changeais décocha un monsieur de 85 ans
qui est même pas conscients que c'est en
train de changer sa couche tissé ces
facteurs pleut je m'excuse de penser à
seul mais mais c'est comme si l'on se le
fait mais temps plein en phase tic garde
cette réalité là elle existe pied on
n'aime pas su y penser et megan voilà il
sait ce qui arrive ça me revient souvent
dit que je parle souvent à ceux
récemment ma soeur a le elle a fait
construire une maison qui s'est
construit le construit maison un duplex
puis à côté c'était maison bis gérance
bigénérationnelle en fait où est ce
qu'il est sa lettre mon grand-père qui
allait vite et puis le mont grands pas
il a en isolement sauf km à ma soeur
avec sa famille à leucate enfants sont
en isolement aussi puis puis mon grand
père il peut être avec les enfants puis
il est tellement content de pouvoir
faire ça en ce moment
puis de pouvoir est entourée de ses
enfants de poètes parce que le lui qui
voit qu est ce qui se passe de cch et
celle des voix qu'est ce qui se passe
avec les personnes de son âge pis il est
tellement content est entouré de sa
famille puis gilles je le comprends donc
si je le comprends pied non pour vrai et
c'est pis je pense que c'était boucar
diouf la semaine passée à tout le monde
en parle qu'ils essayent ils parlaient d
de mourir dans la solitude ça doit être
terrible
savate intérêts mais je ne souhaitais la
fin de ta vie en ce moment où est ce
qu'il y a personne qui peut venir te
voir ses enfants et petits enfants tout
seuls en 2 ch et celle d entourer de
personnes de travailleurs qui sont ultra
dévoué
certes
mais qui en ont plein les bras qui sont
pas capables de t'accompagner comme tu
aimerais pour la fin de ta vie tes du
bas sans tomber trop dans l'homme dans
le leur l'espèce de de philo de base la
mémé l'espèce de voyages qui qui la
seule affaire que tu connais c'est la
fin de ce site il est tout seul si je
trouve ça et je trouve sarov pis pour
ceux que moi même si petit d'homme es-tu
d'accord avec toi moi je le premier à
avoir envie de devoir de la culture
encore le type d'aliments salés
spectacle tout dit mais quand j'entre
voir la possibilité qui avait juste une
personne qui mort dans la solitude en ce
moment parce que j'ai envie d'aller voir
rejects de machines ses plaines
d'abraham
je sais pas du tout ce que j'ai dit zink
que je pense parce que tu dises que la
langue je sais que je sais que je pense
au lycée que c'est ça tu penses à ces
époques
non ce que je faisais mais je dois juste
- mais temps de me dire de prendre ce
risque là je pourrais je pourrai jamais
été un problème qui existait déjà
beaucoup le design et avant le corner
vérisme tout à fait les problèmes
étaient déjà là le petit moment tout le
monde derrière tout le monde à des
réflexions un peu philosophique ou si
justement par rapport à où s'envolent
monde sait quoi nos vies c'est quoi ça
mais tous ces problèmes là il existait
déjà la pandémie fait juste nous les
mettre en plein dedans face le tir cadré
l'on pourrait être un peu psycho-pop le
pire il n'en dépend que de nous de faire
un monde meilleur après tout si
j'écoutais laurent turcot vous
connaissez en tout cas si je l'écoutais
pays disait que la petite dans la
plupart des grands bouleversements que
l'humanité eu le temps des guerres des
choses comme ça mais dans la plupart des
cols l'humanité au poste
significativement changé après tu sais
ça me fait seul ça c'est faux king
capoter le tir parce que c'est le pire
ben ouais type je pense que puis je
pense qu on se rejoint les trois là
dessus on est toutes un peu idéaliste
pour ce conte et vg métier on est toutes
un peu idéaliste faculty c oncert
comment après seul tir après la pandémie
le monde niveau 10 rebonds sapad à
l'heure de travailler comme des fous
sapad à l'heure de scapa planète dans
même si on veut devenir autosuffisants
il faut qu'on arrête l'élevage massive
suis sûr que tout cela se passe dans le
pack com - journée longue
c'est plate peut-être qu'il y aurait
rien de ce qui va arriver
slipknot par le siège et ses deux
petites qu'en france avec les mêmes mots
du problème mot d'ordre est qu'il faut
pas que je pense à ça parce que ça mais
ça c'est du pessimisme pas toucher à
tout écouter ce biais fecteau luketic
qui est parti en croisade plus conquis
conspirationnistes qui seul sur sa page
fan l'oeil était en entrevue avec m je
ne sais pas son nom mais le journaliste
à pied c'est moi je pense qu'après le
savoir devenir exactement comme c'est
d'avoir rien apprendre on va tout oublié
je pense que ces mouches ne marche pas
ce qui est fort entre les deux c'est
vrai que lui mais on oublie rapidement
des fois et puis on peut rapidement
d'autres choses
je pense que le d'affaires qui vont
rester pareil le cpie pitié juste eu si
juste après celle de l'impact mais tant
que tu si certaines personnes gardent le
télétravail comme comme dom obtient
l'utilisent davantage sa les impacts
possibles sur l'environnement presque
tout le monde se déplace moins ses
impacts possibles émotions plus avec art
and i am est positif aussi si le monde
achète plus local c'est si les
initiatives comme le panier brut
un petit peu les balbutiements de
l'histoire affiner mais s'il ya une
plateforme vraiment efficace le fun pour
pau consommer local - dans le far a pas
que ça nous donnerait un petit pilote
cul pour comme changer pour le mieux les
autres que le télésiège celle des je
peux pas croire que ça va rester comme
c'est elle je pense que ceux ci comme on
l'a promis d'en face que c'est sympa de
sentiers ce juge
certain que ça va changer sa pop s'était
déjà c'était déjà un engagement pris par
par la caq lors des élections les
appeler sur les maisons de prêt dont le
c'était comme des maisons pour aînés je
m'appelle puis c'est quoi la publicité
quoi qui voulant ramener façon même de
gérer et à tout ce que tu dis papa
tongres a pas ça me faisait penser si
les pays qui font sur des murs de ma
maison pour un aimant fait pour 10 comme
des garderies mais aussi des maisons se
côtoient tzipi ça serait ça serait
semble-t-il bon pour tout le monde
l'association loos j'imaginais du moins
prêter ses marges et d'avoir un petit
peu de jeunes autour du web comme on
disait tantôt six pilotes vont commencer
des deux pays
je me suis rien passé par cas mais tire
des pays où c'est dans le plus dans la
culture de justement de cette suite des
parents mais tu les gardes proche de toi
quand ils sont vieillissants puis tout
se tient en ce moment à moi j'en entends
des gens autour de moi qui sont comme
hey c'est quoi finalement je regarde ça
je me dis ben coudon ce serait peut-être
une bonne idée si on regarde le monde
qui ont dit plex plus ils sont une
famille là dedans coudon ça c'est
peut-être plus le fun compensées ou de
ces faits que probablement que pour
beaucoup de gens ça va amener des
changements dans leur vie personnelle
sur mon jeu je crois puis c'est une sur
même moment il dit je pense à bain d
affaires le média qui est comme il ya
des affaires qui sont bonnes dans le
confinement puis on se dit bon mais
qu'est-ce qu'on peut réajuster là dedans
même les questions cela va même des
questions vraiment difficiles comme
justement le sait la fin de victime
at-on excuse d'une fin de vie intime et
ont quelqu'un qui dise 15 ans alzheimer
qui reconnaît plus personne sa famille
qui doit naître végétatif si tout
l'acharnement de de maintenir ces
gens-là envie ou sauter tout est
vraiment utile comme gaston pilule très
délicate seppi sauf qu'il faut quand
même que ce n'est là dessus aussi ses 2
jusqu'où site jusqu où c'est de
l'acharnement aussi de plomb lavier
avant tout harman et ses soucis naturel
de mourir ça fait partie du 2 de notre
nature
c'est la vie oui il ya un an je vraiment
spécifique à ce qui est ressorti
d'ailleurs dans la pandémie c'est toute
la question des respirateurs je ne sais
pas si vous avez entendu on peut parler
de tout seul c'est que c'est quand les
gens sont dans un état trop sévère on
les met sur un respirateur qui respire
pour eux et finalement on les met dans
un coma artificiel pendant un bout de
temps alta qui récupère on l'espère puis
tout sera bon puis il ya un médecin qui
a fait une sortie publique le monsieur
plus de son nom mais qui a dit si
j'aimerais juste se rappeler leur que
mettre des personnes sur un respirateur
lebel beaucoup de jeunes a d'abord et
c'est avec des conséquences sévères
des fois même permanente qui a même une
forte proportion des gens qui vont
décéder dans l'année qui suit ces
factions justement c'est comme s'il faut
ça amène des réflexions à savoir chômage
je souhaitais jusqu'où est ce que on
veut entretenir ce je pense qu'avant
c'est comme comme comme je sais quand je
travaillais encore je travaille en 6 h
et celle des lots comme préposée de ses
moyens il ya une unité où je travaillais
jeter des gens vraiment hypothèque il
qu'ils savent avoir enterré parce que je
veux vous dire l'ajusterait probablement
pas le dire mais je relise appareil
nommé pour les faire manger là on
prenait une cuillère tout leur mettait
de la nourriture d'embûches
puis tu fermes et subordonnés puis la
gauche pour que le réflexe de
déglutition se fassent sinon ils
avaleront pas c'est comme si tu les
étouffe la jaiz au sol j'aï sommet c'est
comme si c'est la seule façon pour
qu'ils avalent puis honnêtement au début
mais quand ils m'ont dit perso j'ai fait
non je sais arrivera poti mais si quand
tu dis ce stade le de la ville eux qui
veut se rendre là je veux dire personne
non sens tant pis loeb dans pandémie on
on commence à la voir un peu ces
discussions lot c'est toute la question
des nouveaux ne pourrait animer ne
pourrait susciter une pommette sur
respirateur
c'est benzema qui disent moins sur mon
test à mach peut-être mieux d'être plus
clair le team est minable on tue qu'on
pille a pas dit on est comme jusqu'où je
veux qu'on s'acharne sur moi là bas
c'est classique était dr vadeboncoeur
justement qui parle de type wii se l'est
étaient au sujet de la réanimation cdr
c'était la même affaire c'est comme le
taux de succès de réanimation pour une
personne âgée de 90 ans est vraiment
minime si tu as quelqu'un de la famille
dit non on veut essayer encore on veut
que vous le réanimer la nana qui vont
sortir c'est comme on peut le faire mais
premièrement justement comme titi va
aussi dans ce colis voir des séquelles
l'ailette au succès super beau c'est
prenable de 45 ans qui fait une crise
cardiaque qui on veut le réanimer
pendant quatre-vingt dix ans par maman
faire après ce justement qu'est-ce qui
lui restent à vivre après donc cessé
depuis la question n'est pas de décider
à leur place mais c'est que c'est qu'il
faut que chacun se pose cette question
l'appui que ça soit clair c'est le jour
de la santé commence à être défaillante
ou que tu commences à être dans un
groupe à risque bien malheureusement il
faut que tu prennes des dispositions
pour ça pour que le jour où ça arrive
bah qu'il n'y a pas des décisions qui
repose sur tes proches puis tout ça
puisque tout le monde que tout le monde
capote loti site la rb en théorie au pas
de problème j'imagine que ce sont des
questions qui vont qui vont perdurer
passicos vide ou du moins durant les les
prochains mois du duc au vide
c'était déjà là puis ça fait juste nous
renforce encore on espère que voici ce
que comme tu disais tantôt on espère qu
on a certaines qui vont rester la
pression je voulais qu'on parle
évidemment de
des théories du complot des derniers
mois dans le fond derrière semaine hier
avant hier on a appris
on a appris plus tôt le mais que georges
laraque avait attrapé le lakovic 19 ha
ouais j'ai recueilli je savais pas et
puis
puis il a fait des live à partir de
l'hôpital où est ce qui est typique en
étant piteuse état d'esprit fait de
l'asthme fait qu'il ya vraiment beaucoup
de difficultés à respirer
puis suite à ce il ya eu des
publications qui ont été faites que j'ai
vu passer dans le fait qu'ils ont été
repris par un blog je sais quel blog
mais des publications qui comme de quoi
georges laraque était un pantin pour le
gouvernement puisque c'est un jeu
d'acteur puis qu'il faisait juste parce
qu'avec a fait une publication bien dit
et moi je suis pas sûr qu'on devrait
ouvrir les écoles lol c'est genre moi je
le vilcot vite je vois du monde autour
de moi qui l'ont parce qu'on est tout ça
même étage puis a dit moi je pense qu'il
faudrait peut-être se poser la question
plus longtemps que ceux plus il ya du
monde qui a embarqué la tuer en disant
qu' il y avait été payée par le
gouvernement pour aller dire ce parce
qu'il y était c'est sur un pantin pour
le gouvernement mais son envoi entre que
moi j'en vois tous les jours le passé
sur facebook lé à tous les jours des
enfants comme ceux des complots pick up
c'est pas si grave que ça pis que ça
fait rien spyrus l'up qu'on s'en fout si
débile sont énormes mais ça me fait
capoter exact on s'était parlé un peu
par email à 28 ans tout en avait pas
tant d'entrain mouche garde l'impression
que je garde quand même un infiltrat
c'est serré de ce à quoi je m'expose que
je me rends qu'ils me racontent qui a
manié je devrais peut-être élargir ma
bulle un peu plus parce que parce que de
voir tes devoirs les mauvaises
informations ça peut peut-être aussi
quatre caves a dit reconnaître betty qui
existaient pas qu'il y en a beaucoup
mais oui on a beaucoup moins sage comme
je disais je n'ai pas eu tant que ce mot
les trois principales que j'ai vus par
rapport aux copies je pense qu'ils sont
lippi majeur c'est que le virus avait
été fait en laboratoire en chine que
bill gates serait lié les quelque part
dans tout ce pic troisième c'est que les
literies lien avec le 5 juin le fait
qu'on peut peut-être parler seul e mais
la première cellule de laboratoire cl tu
me laisse le plus perplexe parce que
c'est que les potes des scientifiques
que j'écoutais la grande majorité sont
d'accord sur le fait que le virus bien
la nature sylvie parlement de source
animale
peut-être parce qu'une hypothèse mais il
y aurait eu 10 avec la chauve souris ou
si la rue des marchés le single de pas
l'hypothèse jeu si je me trompe pas je
pense que c'est que le pangolin frais
est l'intermédiaire entre la
chauve-souris et l'humain ce qui est
compliqué c'est une hypothèse
moi c'est sur piste et c'était un marché
pour ces temps un marché en chine que le
monde pouvait consommer des trucs pour
aphrodisiaques le pangolin apparemment
que c'était quelque chose qui est
aphrodisiaque toi et marche et d'animaux
exotiques
mais le deal oeuvre une coupe de jour de
notre homme qui dit on a des infos que c
était fait et en laboratoire
du tout bon c'est de notre homme fait
qu'il soit n'importe quoi comprenant pas
ça au sérieux les you see my pop et aux
états unis qui a dit la même affaire
deux des infos rayon pose la question
justin trudeau
justin trudeau ni infirmé ni confirmé
comme dit tout est sur la table puis on
regarde ce fac jeudi à kiel aller plus
haut il ya cependant tassé soit il était
un peu mou ya quatre mois
sa réponse de ces questions là il est un
peu mou le sais j'ai fait
what quelle que soit la réponse que
c'est ça je m'attendais pas se fait
l'hôte jeudi les plus hauts
les libres et plus hauts dirigeants qui
ont probablement accès d un faucon de
paul pas ceux qui disent qu'ils ont
comme au niveau des états unis dit ce
sont les enfants les formations puis
leur intelligence leur dis que c'est
peut-être ce qui fait que je me dis
qu'il ya peut-être un mini possibilité
que ça soit ça dans le fond je pense que
ça revienne question qu'on a sûrement
déjà jaser il dans nos discussions
passées mais c'est que ça
toujours à la question de s que telle
affaire est possible qu est-ce qu est-ce
que telle théorie super farfelu
extravagantes et possible oui dans le
sens que tout est possible mais ça veut
pas dire qu'il faut qu'on prenne pour
acquis que toutes les théories sont
nécessairement vrai être si j'ose dire
c'est tout simplement une question de
ces comme mike pommes bio puis tout se
gagne le qui disent qu'ils ont dit je
vais pas laisser overwhelming évidente
son enfant de même lorsqu'un bon mais
parfait mais voisines good à table c'est
qui a le fardeau de la preuve le fardeau
de la preuve c'est la personne qui fait
l'affirmation tes collègues année le
deal c'est teddy des désinformations
extravagantes demande des preuves qu'ils
sont autant bon vous avez des preuves
fantastique de son good m'ont même moi
je tout vert à cette idée là moutons
dans l'absolu que ça a été développé en
laboratoire
on n'a pas malheureusement un consensus
d'experts en ce moment que telle à
proximité du virus de génétiquement et
c'est tellement proches avec les choses
qu'on voit chez les animaux exotiques
que c'est presque sûr que ça vient de
l'homme et admettons que ça se pourrait
que ce soit un laboratoire parfait mais
good même shooter l'est l'épreuve je
dirai arrêtez de le dire le puits de new
eyes pipi de nous prouver mais si c'est
pas compliqué mais fixe paumé mais un
moment donné on peut pas commencer à
croire à toutes les théories sans preuve
puis c'est ça le problème dans le
conspirationnisme dans le
conspirationnisme c'est toute forme de
doute et est bonne c'est fait tu peux
douter que la terre est plate c'est
correct parce que c'est un doute
raisonnable
les doutes ne sont pas tous aussi
raisonnables les uns que les autres les
cinq avec toute l'histoire de la
redirection delà du blâme sur les
chinois j'écoutais un reportage du délit
encore une fois qu'ils exprimaient
l'espèce de racisme envers les chinois
que tous sacrés à l'intérieur même des
états unis même des chinois qui sont nés
américains de familles chinoises
immigrants qui ont des ménages aux états
unis qui sont américains à 100% la vague
de racisme que cela crée de rediriger la
faute vers la chine
salle c'est démesuré aux états unis
surtout pour les ceux qui bac trump dans
ce
on a vu évidemment l'image de du space
de trump ou est-ce que c'était marqué
covin nineteen barré marqué chinese
blood ou est-ce que ceux comme pis lui
ai dit à mes personnes ça dérange
personne que j'appelle sur les chinese
flou ça vient la chine qui suite à quoi
un reporter de natifs de la chine d'y
être de quoi tu parles
ça me dérange ça me dérange parce que ça
cultive tout se sait c'est tellement
dangereux
c'est tellement dangereux la façon avec
laquelle l'information est abordée ça me
fait capoter oui tout ça aussi tu
arrives et et la part des mythes arrivé
dans un contexte où on avait plusieurs
raisons aussi de beaucoup de choses à
reprocher à la chine la chine paul les
chinois pour les habitants de la chine
mais la chine le gouvernement la banque
est un gouvernement quasi totalitaire le
petit chapeau si vous avez suivi un
petit peu l'homme et tout le contrôle
extrême que c'est que ce pays-là exerce
sur les cons sur les entreprises c'est
aussi toutes les histoires le corps est
pratiquement des quatre concentration en
chine que les lélés les ddd chinois
musulmans la bosse rekom et captifs que
tout ce que je pense assez crédible
ouah ça semble pas être une théorie de
conspiration de ses piles de la chaîne
ni son enveloppe externe avec toujours
et hervé dans un contexte où il y avait
déjà beaucoup de méfiance envers la
chine est donc l'oeil le flou qui se
créent et puis je pense que tu as raison
c'est qu'il ya beaucoup de racisme
envers les chinois alors que les chinois
jésus ils les chinois ne sont pas leur
gouvernement le sait fait que métier la
chaîne il semble avoir fait des choses
pas tout à fait clair même dans la côte
de 19,6 douala face à la gestion en ce
moment des résultats de données puis
tout l'apparat ma queue puis de nouveau
coaching de la moins qu en chine qu'au
canada
c'est ce qui le problème dans ce cas ci
c'est vraiment la rhétorique ces facs et
la rhétorique vraiment extremis
politique s'est fixé ça c'est rome que
il joue la game du populisme et vauvert
d y joue beaucoup sur les insécurités
d'aidé de ses citoyens c'est sincère ce
son talent dans un sens total à yvorne
et seal
section fanbase c'est majoritairement
des personnes tripper conservatrice dire
un peu raciste s'est fait qu il juste
carte là parce que ça joue contre lui
mais mais c'est contre le gouvernement
chinois qu'on devrait en maudit pas
contre le peuple chinois puis apport
cette théorie là quelles sont celles
toile et victor le plus entendu pays
avec lesquels tu eu le plus de
difficultés en soi même légales sont les
plus importantes mettons qu'on donne aux
autres stars comme étant le très
vigilant de ces informations le bel à la
plus grosse de tout
à mon avis c'est le 5 juin ou peut-être
le fait que ça a été inventé en
laboratoire mais je pense que c'est les
deux théories les plus présentes le fax
et l'idée que tout le déploiement du
réseau cellulaire 5g en ce moment aurait
un lien quelconque avec la corée de 19
kilos c'est quoi le lien le le yoyo 12
versions de cette théorie de
conspiration on leur fait que
vous parlez un peu ok parce que en fait
moi moi je moi je me suis déjà intéressé
à ce sujet leurs avants ben avant la 5g
et loti la question de ces les ondes
électromagnétiques du dangereux sacoche
les maladies des conseils à tout le
monde son électro sensibles du tout ce
type i c'est l'ultime manche où survient
à un manque de compréhension des
principes de base en dessous de ceux ci
un principe de base que je peux citer la
sécu quand tu regardes là quand tu
regardes la bande des ondes
électromagnétiques le jeu dire du
rayonnement nucléaire qui hyper
dangereuse de la radioactivité
mais ça c'est du rayonnement
électromagnétique la lumière les rayons
ultraviolets c'est du rayonnement cessé
de la radiation était dix ondes
électromagnétiques
le white foil les hommes et c'est là
tout ça c'est sur une bande et il ya
différents types d'énergies la dap et
c'est bon t'es la lumière lé la lumière
à laquelle on est exposé aux ide
mais cela c'est plus puissant que toutes
les ondes électromagnétiques le sait
plus puissants que ceux du jamais
entendu parler qu'ont développé des
tumeurs des mutations génétiques à cause
de la lumière
à part les rayons ultraviolets du soleil
qui sont cancérigènes sont on le sait
donc il ya un niveau ou con on est en
danger par rapport à certaines zones
tout ce qui le treut violet
radioactivité rayons x et et ross et
dans la zone qu'on appelle leur et un
maillot nisand mais tout le reste le 6
juillet il ya aucun mécanisme plausible
scientifiquement que si que si que ce
que ce type d'onde le plus être
problématique pour la santé avec la 5g
il à toutes les questions qui entourent
le 5 juin s'est aucunement différents
que pour le 4g s'est aucunement
différents que pour les ouailles faille
s'est aucunement différents que pour le
3g le 2g si tout les mêmes questions que
pour toutes les technologies qu'on a eu
dans un ultime mal tout ça repose sur
une peur des nouvelles technologies
s'est lassé de la seule place d'où ça
vient la seule place d'où ça vient mais
il se dirige plus que comment est ce que
cette idée là farfelues
q nom que non magnétiques comme la 5g
aurait un lien avec avec un pandémie
douce a résulté a donné la vague ayant
reçu un microbiologiste sont non
localisées
c'est christian jacob s'est président de
l'association microbiologie
microbiologiste québec puis lui disais
que dans les vidéos conspirationnistes
sur le 5 g puis coronavirus tous les
procédés tri principe qui explique dans
les vidéos sont souvent vrai mais les
liens entre ces principes le sont
complètement farfelus pyrénées ce qu'ils
disent et qui effectivement qui
utilisent ce jeu c'est donc l'heure pour
prendre pour parfois créer des bactéries
pleut je paraphrase vraiment puis je
t'aime pas royal déçue mais qu utilisent
des justement des ombres de même pour
créer les bactéries mutants mais que
c'est en concentration puis en force
vraiment dit mille fois et un million de
fois supérieure à l'énergie qu'une taux
de 5 g votre aux dires de ses factures
le cast énergie l'oeil a aucune chance
que ça crée des changements dans nos
cellules meilleur sur premièrement c'est
ce que tu dis c'est tout à fait vrai
puis mais l'autre l'autre affaire c'est
que c'est par leur ont toujours été
présente c'est pas nouveau je dire quand
les iommi j'écoutais j'écoutais podcast
récemment avec un spécialiste d'un
physicien que d'un spécialiste de ces
questions là il disait c'est quand le
cas les téléphones cellulaires sont
arrivés sur le marché s'était coincé des
années 80 on a fait quand même le monde
avait déjà pas que ça donne des tumeurs
au cerveau je veux dire ça ça a toujours
été présent dans le cinq j'essaie juste
à chaque fois que chaque fois qu'on
améliore la technologie mais il ya comme
une vague de méfiance qui s'installe
jusqu'à ta queue on a comme un espèce de
une sorte de résilience face à la
technologie pile au moment donné ça ça
les gens abandonnent ces idées
l'observions quand le sujet va venir ou
peu importe le c'est juste c'est
cyclique tu ne me l'avait pas du micro
ondes à base exactement un tipi cesser
la même famille que le micro ondes ça
compte ça donne pas le cancer dans
mesure où je faisais tout mettre la tête
dans le micro-ondes que même là je sais
pas comment tu souffres et sa team et
un micro ondes à habas spots dangereux
ça rend pas les aliments cancérigènes
ça vient ça vient vraiment d'un manque
de compréhension de des choses vraiment
de base puis je peux pas blâmer personne
de faire ça parce qu'honnêtement sait
des choses que même moi le même moi je
connaissais pas vraiment ça va mais
quand tu regardes ce de façon assez
objective des convoqués le 5 g ca
devrait pas nous inquiéter sur le plan
de la santé
il ya peut-être d'autres raisons que ça
nous inquiète le ticket commun ce après
je sais pas s'il faut qu'ils installent
des tonnes de d'antenne tôt parce que
finalement c'est hong lei parcours des
plus petite distance qu'il faut qu'ils
mettent des antennes partout c'est beau
trip en sus économiquement viable de
faire ça je le sais pas les compagnies
qui font souvent tu bien le faire et le
tue plus de possibilités qu'on cesse
pirates et c'est toutes ces questions le
ce correct médication de santé ça a pas
changé par rapport aux sommes en jeu et
que n'importe quel autre technologie
serveur
je veux jouer beaucoup de monde partagé
des entrevues qu'un certain paul héroult
aurait fait qu'ils quittent un
professeur à mcgill le fond les lui qui
est un grand et lui ça serait que les 5
j ils peuvent pas tout à fait les liens
directement avec les chronos virus mais
qu'ils arrêtent tous à des problèmes de
santé qui pourraient être liés à saison
de lutte ce que je pense qu'elles sont
mauvaises mais guy - le lien juste pour
être là parce que là on aura de parler
juste là 5 juillet d'avoir larcher l'a
collé de 19 mais tout ça c'est tout
relié pour une raison super simple c'est
que c'est pour les gens qui sont dans 3
classes alger sa cause des problèmes de
santé
ben l'association et 100 ème cycle la 5g
ça nuit à la santé ça affaiblit le
système immunitaire
donc forcément que tu es plus à risque
d'attraper la coved 19 le don déjà tenté
une conspiration lol ok bon comme est ce
que je pourrai répondre à cette question
là sans avoir une poursuite
mais bon je te réponds n'a rien dit ce
que je lis ce que je voulais dire c'est
qu'ils aiment et en se mettant jeter si
je te disais que j'ai pas vu comme je
disais quand même passé dans mon
facebook clé c'est un de mes amis qui
quelqu'un qui a une tête et épaules qui
partagent soupe ça dit ok segalot que
des études à l'appui
c'est un expert y est prof à
l'université
pikit invités à admirer entier qui est
factice tout des instances de légitimes
légitimité il est dit des choses qui
donnent la crédibilité quand tu dis
qu'ils professent vacances qui était
invité à une émission comme soit devenir
qu'un polar qu'un pardon qui met elle
est ce que tout se est-ce qu'on devrait
prendre tous ceux comme quelque chose
qui donne la crédibilité ou
connaissances
bon bah écoutes je vais j'ai trouvé la
bonne façon de répondre à cette question
les acquis politiques mais qui jouait
déjà donné deux exemples qu'ils allaient
comprendre que je dis ok il ya des
climatologues qui croit pas au
changement climatique qui n'est pas
beaucoup
il ya quelques heures ce à quoi s'est
tue parce qu'un autre exemple qu'il faut
que le on les écoute puis que ils ont
raison c'est non qu'ai je vous donne un
autre exemple plus précis cette fois
l'heure que rapport avait même un
claquage de 19
je poste vous êtes j'ai entendu parler
de luc montagnier way sli à un prix
nobel puis c'est lui une des personnes
qui a dit que ça a été fait en
laboratoire en chine exactement donc lui
si je me trompe pas son prix nobel c'est
qu'il ya été un de ceux qui ont
découvert le lien avec le virus vih là
que je vois pas dire plus que ça je me
suis plus précisément lieu prix nobel
festin king le prix nobel on s'entend
mais le gars après seul ayant cogné
scheer de foule comme l'y a commencé à
dire que les lots dnm était disons
qu'ils avaient de la téléportation là
dedans
il commençait est un partisan de
l'homéopathie le ils viennent dire que
ça a été que le virus d'un manteau
laboratoire puis là je vois plein de
monde sur internet dire oui mieux lien
prix nobel le jeu comme why pis on s'en
fout de tout genre fromenteau bâtisse
exercice assez calmes année ça devient
un peu comment je pourrais pas dire plus
comme le culte de la personnalité la ccq
un moment donné il ya des gens qui sont
comme très charismatique l'appui on
envoie les gens un peu weird leçon
après charismatique fait qu'ils vont
comme armé d'un média puis il parle avec
une sorte de confiance bien une
assurance puis tu as envie de tout à
écouter ce qu'ils disent de tout croire
ce qu'ils disent pyromane et on dirait
que tu oublies comme toute forme de
raisonnement critique se réalisent pas
que 99 points 9 % de tous les autres
experts ne pense pas comme cette
personne là tu fais tout ce que cette
personne je dis est vrai pied que cette
éruption le voit dans tous les domaines
donc on le voit aussi pour la 5 j on le
voit pour pour tout fait que ses statuts
du sens que ça crée une fausse
impression
ça crée une fausse impression qui a aidé
bosse sur les sujets qui n'a pas
vraiment une émission bien vite un
expert pop l'expert content et quand en
réalité les chiffres disent qu'ils ont
un expert peau pour mais l'expert quand
on devrait l'inviter mais le coureur
pour 1.6 puis dire baver tout le monde
doit être représentée donc on évite les
deux poneys des bottes ça donne la
fausse impression qu il n'y a pas de
consensus et un canard exactement
puisque la balance là dedans et pas
nécessairement toujours facile à trouver
puis je peux je peux même donné mon
émission en exemple si dans ma série
telit des fois j'en ai invite des gens
du domaine des pseudosciences pour avoir
une discussion avec eux pour essayer de
comprendre c'est quoi vos arguments
c'est un pilote c'est sûr que quelqu'un
pourrait me reprocher et puis j'accepte
du j'accepte totalement cette critique
là en passant parce que c'est une
réflexion que j'ai moi-même mais
quelqu'un pourrait me dire que je fais
de la fosse balance c'est à dire que je
donne la parole à une personne je n'ai
pas une naturopathe ou autres ou qui
croient à telle ou telle théorie qui
après ça je vais poser la question à un
autre expert je l'aimais les deux sur le
même pied d'égalité
ceci étant dit moi j'ai pas l'impression
que c'est ce que je fais parce que je
vais parler à la personne mais je la
challenge comme un fou tu es giram
dedans comme un train puis tout le reste
l'émission est dédié à essayer de
décortiquer l'argumentaire de ces gens
là et donc à la fin tu dis ben ok on
sentait que le propos marginal ont été
marginalisés maintenant dans les médias
souvent dans un désir de faire du
journalisme dans le désir d'avoir une
certaine neutralité mais les
journalistes ont un bagage de gaulle
l'aï dit que la scène jazz pas bon cette
personne là il dit que
tel produit dans le cancer on va
l'inviter on va l'écouter mais le
jackpot contrepartie 1 puis même si
rennes contrepartie ça donnerait
l'impression que ces deux personnes là
ont des propos équivalent c'est quoi la
solution la solution c'est u2 jamais
éviter ces personnes là ne jamais jamais
leur donner une plate-forme ou si c'est
de le faire dans certains contextes très
précis j'ai pas de réponse à cette
question là mais c'est sûr que bon on
est en tout cas c'est sûr que moi par
exemple quand j'ai vu que j'ai entendu
parler que monsieur et roux avait été
invité à l'émission de paul arcand ce
soir j'ai regardé ça que je me suis dit
si j'ai patrie pays le dans le sens que
c'est parce que ça ça fait qu'on
l'écoutera fait vraiment peur le type
qui devrait même quand tu n'écoutes pas
vraiment l'impression que le 5 juillet
l'électromagnétisme en général on est
tous en danger immédiate s'est fait que
moi c'est ce que je traite pas quand
j'entends quand j'entends ça dans des
médias de surtout d'aider bing
c'est sûr que c'est sûr je demande que
quelqu'un qui écoute sur pie xii le dit
tantôt c'est avec toutes les instances
de légitimisation qui viennent avec son
titre avec son nom avec l'émission à
laquelle ye moi je suis dans mon char
j'écoute ça j'ai pas trop d'expliquer
tic
j'adhère à ce parce que c'est un
spécialiste moi j'arrive chez nous puis
là j'en parle à ma femme j'en parle à
mes amis piloter sa part vite quand même
la wii puis le baby gap même pour être
encore plus clair le moins de problème
que j'ai eu avec des situations comme ça
c'est pas que ces personnes laziale tel
ou tel propos croix à telle ou telle
théorie ou et cetera
mais c'est que si s'ils veulent faire la
preuve de leur théorie exemple que le 5
g us et c'est mauvais pour la santé ou
et cetera
mais c'est des choses comme cela on peut
le faire on peut le faire dans la
communauté scientifique
surtout que quand tu es chercheurs bête
c'est facile fait de la recherche de la
bonne recherche de qualité publient
leurs puis le des boys devra avoir lieu
dans la communauté scientifique qui
s'est débarrassé constant quand tu
regardes les publications aux chercheurs
le cedi chicane constante
en gros le sait ça c'est des chercheurs
qui se chicanent parce qu'on va trouver
talent à faire lors de trouver le
contraire les deux chicanes
là ils font intervenir des experts de
l'extérieur pour finalement faire un peu
de la la médiation lathus les débats
devraient pas avant lui dans les médias
moi c'est seul problème que j'ai parce
que quand je mets ça dans les médias ça
donne l'impression aux gens qui ont un
doute que tous ceux des boléros déjà été
réglées dans la communauté scientifique
ça veut pas dire qu'il faut pas avoir de
débat c'est fait monsieur roux par
exemple moi j'ai aucun problème je
trouve ça correct qui qui qui qui qui
tiennent à ces théories mais mais mais
ça devrait pas être fait dans les médias
ça devrait être fait sur dans la
communauté scientifique pis c'est pas du
tout faire la communauté scientifique
considère que tout ce qui a trait aux 5
g puis le lien avec les effets sur la
santé
ben oui oh rien ne s'est fait ok c'est
fait ouais absolument ben oui c'est sûr
il ya des tonnes de recherche là dessus
je pense je pense que la même l'année
passée il est sorti une gigantesque
étude de john rich aux états unis qui
avaient été faits sur
une grosse grosse étude qui avait défait
sur des robes qui avaient été exposées à
des ondes électromagnétiques et si je
dois d'ebola aux lieux déjà dans la
communauté scientifique mais à toutes
les fois qu'on le fait on n'est jamais
capable de 2,2 on n'est jamais capable
de trouver des preuves convaincantes
comme quoi que les ondes
électromagnétiques non ionisants
donc tout ce qui est 5 g c'est lui là où
il fallait tout de suite gamble
on n'est jamais capable de trouver des
preuves convaincantes que c'est
problématique pour la santé enfin vu
qu'on n'est pas capable de trouver ça
dans le débat scientifique ne devrait
pas menacer la place publique quand l on
va juste faire capoter le monde pour
rien c'est que puis le futur l'air la
responsabilité je vais prendre ça
différemment avec les médias sociaux
maintenant tout le monde une tribune
tout le monde une tribune au toac is
tout le monde peut dire ce qu'ils
veulent sur leur tribune ça c'est la
liberté de chacun de dire ce qu'ils
veulent sur leur prix bleus maintenant
est-ce qu'on exerce un contrôle sur des
choses extrêmes comme des groupes
terroriste sur facebook ou est ce qu est
ce que ce que les médias sociaux
devraient intervenir c'est elle et son
saut de côté pour l'instant mais tout le
monde a une tribune maintenant car on
élargit le discours qu'on voit dans les
instances de les utilisations des
moments de haute et que les émissions de
l'être comme tout le monde en parle par
exemple comment est ce qu'on fait pour
contrôler l'information sans faire de la
censure systématique du monde qui sont
qui vont contre le consensus
scientifique m'étonne moi c'est comme
cette question là parce que moi bunce si
si je réponds moi même de qu'est ce que
je ferai évidemment que moi j'établirai
un des critères de sélection des sujets
abordés puis d'aider des opinions émises
sur des émissions a ôté coûte qui sont
qui ont un réel impact dans la société
qui sont pas des médias sociaux qui sont
pas le compte facebook d'intel mais
éthiquement est-ce que ça se fait
sèchement 6 et c'est une question
c'est une question à se poser je pense
comment est ce que en tant que société
on gère ce genre d'information le
comment est ce qu'on fait
- betty tu te parler de censure pis
c'est juste faire attention dans le sens
où les gens qui ont des théories non
appuyées scientifiquement d'aucune façon
de ne pas leur donner une plateforme
sppa de les censurer certains le
faisaient ils ont été horribles sont
même pas capables de l'appuyer d'aucune
façon t'es pas en très petite censure
paul jaud pourquoi est-ce qu'on peut
sinon on va commencer à écouter tout le
monde qui vole la moyenne la première
personne qui en théorie farfelue on va
lui donner une plateforme j'adore ça
fonctionne pas comme ça c'est en fait je
pense que les médias la responsabilité
qu'ils ont c'est que avant d'inviter une
personne
ils devraient s'informer à savoir sept
personnes là qui va venir me parler le
de coups et cascades représente comme
opinion
ok parce que tout ce qu'on dit ultime
ans et des opinions la crise une opinion
un prêtre personnel ça peut être
professionnel et cetera donc l'opinion
qui va me présenter sur l'opinion qui
est partagé par
la majorité des gens dans son milieu est
ce que c'est une opinion qui est plus
marginale
ce tu as une opinion qui est disons un
sujet à controverse dans le milieu
scientifique
si les médias font cet exercice là moi
je suis correct je médias au québec où
lyon fait l'exercice
mais souvent ils font pas souvent ils
vont juste faire quand il était le gars
qui parle de telles affaires je
l'invitais watts et tim moi je quand je
parle à des journalistes je leur dis
souvent chèque si jamais ça vous tente
le rendez vous voulez parler de tels
sujets pdte n'hésitez pas à m'appeler
pas pour que je sois l'expérience moi
j'ai pas tout léger pas toutes les
époques toutes les jeunes expertise mais
n'hésitez pas à m'appeler père me
demandais quel suspense de telles
personnes informées le mans le genre que
je voudrais te nomine il parle mais fait
je sentais qu'il me le demandez si je
vais vous donner mon avis fait là avec
deux trois personnes de confiance que
vous avez parce que c'est un petit
milieu d'un petit monde a le monde dit
le monde et des ddv de la science
bizarre le steam c'est un petit milieu
enfin de bâtir une sorte de relation de
confiance comme ça avec des journalistes
moi je pense que c'est une chose qu'on
peut faire mais il va toujours y avoir
des médias qui vont prendre leur propre
décision parce que vont il faut qu'ils
arrivent et cetera fait que ce serait
aussi c'est qu'on vit dans un moment
c'est un méchant radio canada peuvent se
permettre de trier comme ils veulent
parce qu'ils sont pas nécessairement
tributaire de de toutes les clés coup
les écouter alors que beaucoup des
missions qui vont savoir apporter
beaucoup plus d'avoir quelqu'un qui qui
vient comme se parler à des hordes haute
écoute d'un sujet polarisant que de
recevoir encore une autre personne qui
vient parler de la même chose que toutes
les autres s'est fait qu'il tout l'enjeu
des écoutes qui déclic de qu'est ce qui
fait que les gens écoutent ce j'ai
l'impression que ça ça vient créer
encore plus de distorsions dans le
discours public
il ya non seulement comme le dit non
seulement ça mais aussi jeux la réalité
qui est aujourd'hui depuis deux ans
d'avoir une tribune officielle comme
radio-canada pour te faire entendre et
pis les bains les gens qui ont aucune
triptyque est leur seule tribune c'est
youtube mais qui sont attendus par
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de monde le
teint
donc ce première des choses il ya ceux
qui deuxièmement parallèlement à son
drake une espèce de méfiance
grandissante des gens générale envers
justement la classe politique puis les
médias étaient donc ces deux éléments à
leur ensemble c'est une recette pour un
désastre wapiti tout à fait raison le
jeu surtout dans l'attique comme la
pandémie en ce moment on a vu une sorte
de montée de tous les médias alternatifs
puissent a rejoint tous les gens
justement qui ont de méfiance envers les
médias de masse traditionnels donc ils
vont les trous ils vont la trouver la
désinformation à quelques pas avec moi
si c'est comme si ça fait plus 2012 le
que je fais de la communication
scientifique mon attitude par rapport
aux médias l'ont drake a changé à toutes
les années et des années où je suis
fâché contre eux de l'année d'après je
me dis moi mais dans le fond de 6
on a besoin de lui ils font quand même
plus du bon travail que du mauvais
travail l'année d'après goethe encore
forgé kilos l'année d'après je me dis ou
un blanc travail pas facile puis c'est
fait si on pourrait dire ouais même
emmené telle ou telle émission de radio
où radio can où nombre de quitter vérone
est en fait l affaire de croche mais le
premier beaucoup plus grave que seul le
problème c'est si le problème c'est ça
c'est le nom d'une source de
désinformation et juste immense le pipi
les personnes qui doutent vont de moins
en moins prendre leurs infos dans les
médias classiques ce qu'est ce qui
pousse à ton avis quelqu'un a sombré là
dedans ce que c'est ce que s'il apporte
que c'est l'inconnue est ce qu'on essaye
justement de remplir l'inconnu avec des
réponses qu'on en a pas parce que parce
que naturellement comme avec la religion
ce qui est chose qu'on faisait on est on
crée flamand des réponses avec l'inconnu
plus on fait la même chose et que ses
théories de est ce qui s est dit quoi
pourquoi ça existe c'est pas clair s'il
ya eu un peu de la recherche sur le le
conspirationniste par exemple la pensée
conspirationnistes qui à l'origine la
théorie c'est que c'était interdit et
s'était associée à des traits de
personnalité puis c'est quand même
pâques la mjc les recherches sont pas
aussi concluante à ce niveau la fecq
avant on pouvait se dire par exemple tel
type de personnalité ça va donner une
personne qui a tendance à tomber dans le
conspirationnisme damas est plus
complexe
ce puits ou si une chose qui moi même
j'ai appris le sait que dans des filets
après ce décor réalisé mais dans toutes
nos villes dans nos vies à nous trois
tout le monde on va croire en théorie de
conspiration ou d'une autre à un moment
donné c'est donc en réalité si on peut
tous croire à des théories de
conspiration peut-être la différence
c'est que il faut faire je passe une
différence entre croire une théorie de
conspiration versus faire la promotion
active de théories de conspiration c'est
la même histoire que pour les là les
mouvements anti vaccin anti devant
ti'vac c'est des gens qui sont anti
vaccins qui pousse l'information ati
vaccin sur le web y en a pas beaucoup
déjà comparé des vaccins et en plus
c'est avec des conspirationnistes purs
et durs sas a fait probablement plus
partie de leur personnalité
tandis que des gens qui vont croire
mettons ces bateaux est en tout qui
disait que c'était 50 % des gens qui
avaient un doute sur les informations
officielles ou quand tu es au lycée cité
comme un ver nous sommes pas de bons
services et j'en lis pas tout des
conspirationnistes convaincu non mais
nous autres même je pense que on
rentrait dans cette catégorie de
l'essence qui dépense et que le
gouvernement ne me pas toute
l'information
si possible pas farfelue passé c'est non
mais dans le même article je disais que
j'étais tanné de voir qui apparemment
chez les jeunes est vraiment plus une
préparation aux conspirationnistes que
chez les personnes plus âgées pourrait
penser ces contraintes
une génération un peu plus informés
allumé avec axel informations sinon ça
serait une belge contente que tu
soulèves ce point là parce que ton on a
beaucoup beaucoup shiro les contres les
baby boom 1 depuis quelques années au
québec mais en fait c'est que le sait
qu'à un moment donné c'est comme c'est
comme si tout le mal du monde c'est
devenu les baby boomers
tu as raison les lilas la frange
conspirationnistes ya un mouvement quand
même assez fort chez les jeunes qui il
ya aussi un mouvement que
que moi je trouve assez inquiétant c'est
un peu comme ce que je pourrais appeler
du conspirationnistes de nouvelle
génération ou du conspirationnistes d'
entertainment
c'est comme si toute une vague de deux
jeunes qui font des cds youtuber cdd
podcast qui font ils
ils présentent pas comme ça mais d'ici
du conspirationnisme donc ça va être par
exemple des podcasts ou des youtube et
qui font dire à et moelleux je parle de
jeu prend dix cols et illico de
quelqu'un qui est mort pire c'est qu'on
n'a jamais vraiment su la vérité peluche
doivent présenter toutes les théories
là-dessus psych sûr que vous en
connaissez le qui fondera n'aurait su
sunshine en a reçu une balle mais c'est
sûr j'ai pas besoin de nommer non le
métier puis sérieusement le cadre
d'études ihs vraiment ce que ces gens le
font il présente tout le temps ça comme
j'ai fait une bonne recherche puis je te
présente vraiment toutes les théories
valides qui en réalité le cheval en cinq
minutes de recherche la taille est
capable de trouver que wade gelé jeudi
qu'ils étaient un signe ou buzz c'est
qui fait du tout cramer qui fêtait la
conspiration aussi puissamment en a fait
moins maintenant parce qu'elle s'est
aperçue que tu sais plus à faire
attendre plus des forces nouvelles qui
est vraiment qui faire de quoi de
constructif l'ofac maintenant peu plus
du tout quand même des trucs
il débreake sont vraiment arrivés pour
ouais mais le problème c'est qu'il ya
énormément de conspirationnisme dans le
truck rhymes parce que souvent les
youtube les palais les podcasts ou qui
font ce genre d'affaires le ils vont
dire ok je vais vous présenter le cas
voici la version de la police
mais voici toutes les autres théories
qui ont été présentés avec ses persos
n'est peut-être pas vraiment à ce
n'était pas vraiment suicidé un tir qui
a été aussi évoquée que tel a fait la
fête la fatala fatale à faibles et vont
remettre comme toutes les théories pour
finalement remettre en doute la version
officielle
mais ce qu'est ce que ça fait en réalité
ce que ça fait c'est que ça crée une
méfiance envers les autorités
donc ça veut dire quoi métier la police
le on sait bien anti nous donne telle
affaire puis la version officielle puis
tout shopi on le sait la que des fois
c'est sûr ça existe des fois des cas où
effectivement la version officielle pour
la bonne piste mais quand c'est tout le
temps le même que moi j'ai été un peu un
peu moi même victime de thuram en et
j'écoutais un podcast de 2,3 c'est
vraiment le fun qui tout bien manger il
y avait des cas que je t'ai caffin et
enfin 10 épisodes chez com
il coûte marche pas là dedans puis
j'allais lire sur le coq qui en l'espace
de cinq minutes le jld avait très
clairement rapidement trouvé que c'était
de la baule shit le qu'il y avait des
preuves très très très solide et non
réfutable aussi à l'effet que la version
officielle est à la bonne version
mais quand j'écoute l épisode du podcast
on me présentait sa comme système ben
non finalement toutes les théories spurs
puis finalement bel et recherche des
fameuses recherche que le monde font pas
ce qu'ils vont sur leur ai dit
puis ils vont sur des espèces de deux
cercles de discussion de sur dix au
brésil deux trous 'crime que c'est du
semis conspirationnisme c'est un fake
c'est en tout le début de ces
discussions le steak elliott du
conspirationnisme chez les jeunes mais
justement c'est que si tu si tu te
donnes pas les bases d'esprit critique
aux jeunes est ce que ça donne c'est que
ça donne un moment donné une méfiance
qui s'en vont dans toutes les directions
c'est correct d'avoir un bon niveau de
méfiance le chu le premier je répète
souvent surf c'est correct d'être
méfiant avant les grandes entreprises
déjà fallu si les ce et quand de tout le
temps de la version officielle après
tout doute la version officielle de tout
petits puisqu'on aime parler vaccin est
vraiment bon il est vrai que les cinq jc
sécuritaire assuré que l'accord est de
19,6 à ça a été une maladie naturelle
c'est moi je pense que ça comme moi je
pense à ça part mal la vie on est usé de
le commencer à tout de suite c'était
coût total du 3eme qui sont tout le
temps en train de dire que la police est
au tout faux puisque finalement c'est
peut-être autre chose bas intyamon et tu
finis par juste et les les gens qui ont
légère tendance à à croire à ceux des
affaires de même je pense que ça va les
mener dans un dans un chemin qui à mon
avis assez dangereux ruth légeret pas
sur ce genre de podcasts le etc nous
autres on le voi t on des fonds quand on
sort un podcast mettons qu'on écrit dans
les tags
c'est à dire les tic les mots clés que
le monde peuvent chercher quand on écrit
conspiration vraiment qu'on va le faire
aussi encore pour ce podcast le lin on a
joué on voit directement qu'on attire
des gens qui cherchent sur son sur
youtube qui cherche le mot conspiration
des gens qui sont pas bonnes à notre
chaîne
excuse moi des gens qui sont
aucune raison apparente de connaître et
arnaud se lit par exemple des gens de
france qui arrive qu'ils cherchent
conspiration pic qui doivent passer des
heures et des heures et des heures sur
youtube a cherché des vidéos de
conspiration tout juste par avidité
d'avoir des théories pipe remax l'a
amené à force d'en à force de te faire
dire que tu es beau tu dis que des
bowlings mais je pense tu sais pas si le
fond du problème c'est que c'est
vraiment un truc et des vidéos derrière
nous doit faire comme ceux n'existant
pas réussi parce qu'on aimerait son prix
croire si on n'a pas ça nous soit vrai
existantes et l'a clairement dit au
début oui j'ai une phase plus jeunes à
manier antiques et des vidéos le d
eliane génétique et une coupe des vidéos
de 2001 le site en septembre tpiy
c'était un crime s'intéressant plus de 5
g pote cinq hommes privilégient d'abord
cette information là comme s'ils
savaient quelque chose que les autres ça
les autres savent peu comme trésor
national depuis qu'un petit commence à
découvrir des affaires mais excitant de
penser qu'il attendait des
extraterrestres printemps puisque le fun
si mam amnésique athlètes regarde
tellement qu'il fabriquera pauvre wipi
des recettes cette vision des choses
c'est pas mal là là l'hypothèse actuelle
effectivement seixas de croire des
théories de conspiration ça te fait
sentir spéciale cette fournée un groupe
d'appartenance
c'est parce que tout d'un coup tu crois
plus la version officielle des affaires
et là tu découvres tout un nouveau
cirque social de jacques sont un peu
comme toi dans un sens et l'autre de
couteau est la vérité les autres les
gens sont des moutons plomb le tant
attendu le mouvement breton
si on pense que la copie de 19 tonnes
pandémique et hervé à cause du hasard on
est des moutons tués avec toi tu es
spécial tôt eu accès à de l'information
qui est privilégié qui unique les autres
c'est des moutons sont dans l'ignorance
qui
petit puis finalement mais tout d'un
coup tu découvre un nouveau groupe
d'appartenance qui te fait sentir plus
normalisée c'est drôle parce que je
travaille sur un autre projet en ce
moment un autre projet qui aura pas avec
les sectes qui moi j'ai parti de zéro ou
le genre je connaissais rien sur les
sectes puis dans les derniers mois je
travaillais foule la tuque j'ai vraiment
appris à comprendre le fonctionnement
d'un siècle et la pensée secteur
honnêtement c'est la même affaire le
conspirationnisme plis groupe
conspirationnistes essentiellement ceux
des sectes de mon point de vue en tout
cas tout les mêmes mécanismes sont
l'auteur leader charismatique donc tout
autant de personnes en tête que tout le
monde admire cette personne le sait des
affaires elle a aussi dit chanel de
communication que c'est pas tout le
monde qui ils font sentir spéciales et
d'histoire choisi parce que tu as
quelque chose de spécial toi tu as la
vérité et tous les autres sont dans
l'ignorance ou dans l'erreur
c'est une forme de cercles
essentiellement puis aussi comme un côté
comme toudic qui est un peu comme une
drogue etc dis moi même quand j'étais
jeune j'étais beaucoup comme ça j'ai
même acheté abonnés à québec paranormal
où je me suis plus comment ça s'appelait
le met toute la crapule de justement les
extraterrestres les affaires je tripais
là dessus je je je je m'abreuve ait
d'autres sujets mais vraiment ce
jusqu'au jour où on m'a dit j'ai fais
toi mais finalement c'est entertaining
mais j'étais juste ça mais mais mais où
je pense qu'un côté addictif clairement
c'est l'idée l'idée de détenir ça me
fait vraiment je trouve que c'est pas
que ça me fait rire mais l'idée l'idée
de détenir la vérité l'été puis de de
vouloir l'exposé pique les gens
l'entendent
quant au jeu mettant je vais prendre
l'exemple du véganisme gay - ch
je croit détenir une vérité que c'est
pas tout le monde qui ont dit que j'ai
envie de la donner aux gens c'est une
vérité basée sur la science avec une
certaine esprit critique
mais l'espèce de feeling que j'ai de
faire on my god faut que tout le monde
le sache pour que le message passe
comprend
vous réalisez pas sûr j'ai l'impression
que quelqu'un que pas l'esprit critique
pour ferrer là l'analyse une fausse
données puis d'un complot comme ça j'ai
l'impression que le sentiment doit être
le même le frère ou ma gueule
j'ai une vérité il faut que vous
l'entendiez ça me fait rire l'espèce de
voir ces deux choses le devoir que le
feeling au final doit être le même outil
oui et puis j'avais lu amende et un
article je pourrais vous le retrouvez
sans jamais s'y intéressent mais sa
veste et ej pas je me soumets un
bookmarklet eu des matchs sur ce
trimestre et une analyse psychologique
du du végétarisme et du végétalisme qui
à la base ça vient d'une forme de sa vie
d'un sentiment de supériorité morale
qu'on n'aime pas ça se faire dire ça
mais c'est pareil parce que tu penses
que tout le monde est dans le champ d'un
puis tu penses que ce que tu fais c'est
la bonne façon de faire
sais tu dis le moi je vais pu tuer des
animaux un jeu pu nuire à
l'environnement bla bla bla est ce que
je fais c'est bien mieux qu'ils vu que
je pense que c'est mieux battus tout
devrait convaincre les autres fai qui en
côte et rennes il ya un côté un peu un
regard dans un sens la date pas d'hier
que c'est bien avisé ou mal avisé mais à
la base c'est ce pari fait qu'une fois
que tout ça tu peux plus ne pas le
savoir
et à partir de là bas si ça tu vas juste
essayé de pousser ta théorie ce qui va
faire la différence après ça va être
probablement des des caractères vraiment
purement individuelle dans la mesure où
si comme maintenant vous devez le titre
du monde raisonnable qui ai pas envie de
se chicaner tout le temps avec tout le
monde
vous êtes capable de maintenir des
relations harmonieuses dont vous allez
être capable d'avoir des bosses sain
avec une personne d'en discuter qu'après
10 ou 20 j'accepte que l'on pense pas
pareil toit puis - seul l oms est un
autre point m6 que rapport avec les
cercles je m'excuse revenir là dessus
mais là c'est quand même là l'élite mais
ton exemple les lidl de siècle par
exemple un des points les plus
caractéristiques c'est leur refus de se
faire contredire
il refuse que jamais les contredire ces
gens là jamais tu vas avoir raison avec
eux les conspirationnistes un peu pareil
mais mais tu vois me ton vous autres
matois ph le ttt vegan 6 mai
je pense pas que si quelqu'un te dis ben
moi je suis pas pour se lever ganis tu
va l'envoyer chier tu étais capable
d'avoir une vraie conversation quand
même et que cette personne l'appui de
rester bons amis même si la personne
n'est pas capable de comprendre les
classes à un moment donné c'est comme si
tu dépasse le stade de juste je suis un
sentiment de supériorité morale mais en
même temps capable de concevoir que
c'est pas tout le monde qui pensent
pareil que c'est correct
j'ai réalisé un article de l'ado canada
justement qu'ils étaient deux
témoignages de personnes qui ont de
leurs proches
sombre de plus en plus dans les théories
de complot à un point que je demande
c'est si ils sont complètement coupés de
leur entourage ils sont pratiquement
pouillon puis jobs son jeu sur internet
c'est bien je les lui aussi c'est à dire
exactement sur les mêmes mécanismes une
secte qui même que en ce moment les
l'organisme infosec reçoit plus d'appels
d'aed qu'à l'habitude de dire qu z comme
un virus puisse me ferai ce que je
trouve intéressant c'était quoi faire
dans ces colonnes
parce qu'on aurait tendance à vouloir
contre-argumenter puisse y faire voir la
vérité ou faire voir aussi que les
raisonnements fait défaut à ces
personnes là mais plus tu fais ce plu à
personne c'est continuer son chemin
était plus ça renforce sa position
quelle est la raison qui te manger vite
et mieux quasiment de rien fois en fait
est mieux de rien faire garder un lien
confiance ces personnes là pour que
17h45 garde un petit contact avec la
réalité
plutôt que de couper le pont parce que
si je commence à comprendre elle va
probablement coupé le pont comme comme
on le tout et joyeux un ami qui est dans
une relation malsaine piste et s'est dit
dit ressentir la situation faut juste
garder un lien de confiance puis espérer
que la personne sa rencontre d'allemand
un jour un match complet fait exactement
ce que des délits croyances extrêmes le
par rapport à n'importe quoi que ça peut
être des idéologies politiques que c'est
justement des conspirationnistes secteur
extérieur c'est identitaire
donc ces gens là c'est pas juste des
croyances et j'essaie croyances l'ag
cette idéologie la mesa défini qui je
suis
c'est quand tu les contredite et pas
juste en fait contredire des croyances
tenterait de les attaquer dans la fibre
de qui sont faits c'est sûr que hiré
agissent agressivement qui en plus les
chances que tu puisses les convaincre
qu'ils sont nuls donc pas mal puis moi
je parle à des experts dans le domaine
des siècles par exemple mais on peut
faire le parallèle encore une fois
puisqu'il dit c'est la même affaire ce
qu'ils disent ces gens là en gros ce que
tu fous que tu leur dise le même site
approche le maton que c'est amer foutons
frère ou vauxhall à 10 je t'aime je vais
accepter des croyances je ne partage pas
les mêmes mais je t'aime quand même et
j'espère qu'on va être capable de de
continuer à maintenir une relation
ensemble malgré nos divergences de
points de vues date is it c'est tout ce
que tu peux faire c'est d'être là pour
elle puis le le le si cette personne là
un moment donné parce que moi depuis le
début de la pandémie leur en fait
surtout depuis que j'écris mon article
sur les la pensée conspirationnistes
j'ai eu quelques personnes qui m'ont
écrit en privé sur twitter pour entre
autres pour me dire à moi je te nanciers
conspirationnistes puisse sortir de tout
ça il ya personne qui aurait pu m'en
faire sortir la seule personne qui m'a
fait sortir c'est moi même
il ya un gars qui m'a dit que c'était un
divorce pillot
il ya quelqu'un d'autre qui m'a dit que
c'était après je pense y avait perdu son
emploi ou quelque chose comme ça c'est
le moteur de changement si on arrive à
venir de l'intérieur
la personne va vivre un bouleversement
super grand qui va l'amener à revoir ses
valeurs puis c'est comme ça que les gens
sortent des sectes qui prend le maxi
comme ça que les gens sortent du
conspirationnisme aussi si c'est le cas
c'est rohff serov quand même comme comme
proposition d'imaginer que c'est un
spirale sans fin
oui parce qu'on est des idéalistes on
aimerait six mois ça me forge ça me
fâche de devoir dire cette cdm voyant je
n'accepte pas qu'on puisse rien faire
mais des fois tu mets des fois d'avoir
de l'empathie envers les gens c'est ça
aussi c'est d'accepter qu'on peut pas
changer leur point de vue tu es ce que
cela doit vraiment un bon point excuse
moi je me faire une autre mental de deux
seuls d'avoir d'empathie avec les gens
c'est d'accepter qu'on pourrait pas
nécessairement leur faire changer d'idée
c'est vraiment une bonne bonne
formulation s'cusez moi donc je les
coupe et j'ai décollé manche à utiliser
mais est ce que selon toi nier que
maintenant les changements climatiques
sont causées par l'homme
est ce que c'est une forme de
conspirationnisme parce que c'est parce
que ce serait pour beaucoup moins coup
de jeune à ce stade si oui parce que
dit-il en fait c'est un peu comme la
vaccination le secteur magnéto un
consensus scientifique tellement solide
que si toi tu ne crois pas au consensus
pour que ta théorie soit valide il faut
qu'ils aillent des dizaines voire des
centaines de milliers de personnes donc
des scientifiques des gens du
gouvernement que cette erreur qui sont
tous dans le coup puis les changements
climatiques c'est pareil ils ont laissé
le liant au consensus
extrêmement solide à l'effet que c'est
réel c'est ici ces man made en bonne
partie que cette erreur donc si tu y
crois pas ça veut dire que tu pense
qu'il ya une une énorme quantité de gens
qui activement monte à la population
donc oui ça devienne théories de
conspiration j'ai l'impression qu'il ya
beaucoup de gens qui croient pas parce
qu il
parce qu'ils veulent pas croire parce
que ça impliquerait qu'il faudrait qui
effectue des changements c'est la vie
c'est ça je pense que je commence sim et
ont avoué que les changements
climatiques sont sont causées par
l'homme ça voudrait dire que un
bouleversement dans mon statut socio
politique ne outils juste le fait de se
sentir que j'étais toujours à l'avant de
la file qui le curé leye à l'arrière de
la salle quand je réponds succès puis je
pense que le conservatisme en général
puis si je peux faire des parallèles
boiterie métier j'écoutais une intro
farah sens politique qui est experte un
changement climatique dit en général on
remarque plus tu es à droite sur le
spectre politique
- tu as de chances de penser que les
gens mathématiques son côté palm pilot
si c'est aux états unis probablement et
a dit parce qu'en réalité c'est de la
peur c'est de l'apport de changement si
l'apport de changement à tous les
niveaux aussi changé ma vie j'aurai mon
truck d'abord devoir concéder un petit
parti d'un mode misaki demi privilège ni
pouvoir à d'autres cités mais c'est un
cas particulier parce que c'est pas
nécessairement toutes les idéologies qui
sont drivés par les mêmes affaires cu de
la recherche là dessus un peu le karma
mpi tu vois le lac rôti le fait de
croire ou d'avoir confiance en le
consensus scientifique en lien avec les
changements climatiques s'est fortement
drivée par l'idéologie politique
donc ceux spécifiquement cité mettons
effectivement conservateur à droite
républicains aux états unis il ya des
fortes chances est un c'est le principal
loin des principaux facteurs de risque
pour ne pas faire confiance
les chiffres le prouvent les
statistiques le prouvent le cpo un nom
exact le ya eu des recherches là dessus
par contre c'est pas vrai pour tout les
pauvres et pour toutes les idéologies
outre les théories de conspiration
exemple le mouvement antivaccin et le
mouvement anti ogm qui sont deux
théories de conspiration c'est des
mouvements de gauche c'est pas des
mouvements de droite donc donc c'est pas
dit pas c'est qu'ils sont pas tous en
lien avec
la gauche ou la droite politique cette
intéressante et avant qu'on va conclure
qu'on utilise toute la journée
il vient je voulais que je voulais qu'on
parle un petit peu qu'on revienne sur
avant le podcast en fait dans tous les
envoyés de liste de sujets qu'on voulait
qu'on pouvait laboris internet à
élaborer moi j'aimerais qu'on vienne sûr
parce que je sais que tu as fait une
épisode là dessus de ton émission sur la
conversation qu'ont eue avec berne en la
vallée et catherine la fin vers la fin
de ce parc à jeux les réécouter hier
vers la fin du podcast on parle de de
l'obésité on parle du poids
puis on parle de la sent lié à la santé
en fait la thèse qui est défendu ou ou
qu'on consomme à être en accord c'est de
dire que c'est pas parce que tu es gros
qui était en mauvaise santé exact c'est
ce qu'on sait ce qu on s'est entendus
puis ce je pense que ça fait du sens de
dire sur cette affirmation le fait dix
ans maintenant toi tu étais pas tout à
fait confortable discours avec nos
discussions ce qu'on peut élaborer là
dessus je pense que ça intéresse
beaucoup de gens parce que chaque fois
qu'on parle de ça il ya beaucoup de
réactions indignées dans les communs web
et c'était pas du sommet que je t'ai pas
confortable mais c'est que il ya
certains aspects ou si comme ce que tu
désires par exemple je pense que ceci
c'est vrai c'est même pas c'est même pas
controversé de dire si le poids d'une
personne à la base ça détermine pas sa
santé et y suivre une personne qui a un
poids plus élevé qui est un super bonne
santé d'une personne qui est un peu plus
faible et en suis pas mauvaise santé de
ces faits que le le le danger c'est qu
on est toujours un peu véhiculer l'image
que le poète a été un facteur de risque
toujours pour la santé alors que c'est
pas toujours le code c'est le mot love
le malaise que j'ai c'est qu'il ya un
discours ambiant en ce moment où là
c'est comme ça on est poussé sont un
petit peu trop lointain
il ya tout un mouvement super positif
puis j'en parle dans mon épisode sur le
pwa d'ailleurs tout le mouvement anti
grossophobie anti diète et ses terrasses
c'est un mouvement qui est très positif
on avait vraiment besoin de tueur c'est
d'arrêter deux fois que je suis sur le
poids est d'arrêter de diriger les gens
vers des méthodes de perte de poids tout
ça c'est hyper positif mais il ya un
autre mouvement qui est apparue ça c'est
toujours comme ce caillou du thé dans
les mouvements militants qui est haute à
un moment donné une frange qui se crée
qui vote juste un petit peu trop loin
ce mouvement là qui étaient beaucoup
présent un peu dans les derniers mois
son voeu ça a été un mouvement qui est
pratiquement au niveau du déni à
l'isthme de l'obésité est par contre
c'est à dire que ma nièce et kamba
l'obésité ça n'existe plus on peut plus
utiliser le mot obésité study parle
d'obésité c'est grâce au club et que
cette erreur c'est pile un moment donné
c'est comme si certains profitaient de
la santé même qu'ils sont un peu qu'ils
font un peu là dedans ce moment pythie
moi j'ai vraiment un malaise par rapport
à ça parce que c'est comme si l'on
mélange deux concepts si c'est vrai que
le poids d'une personne ne termine pas
sa santé mais quand on parle d'obésité
là on parle pas juste d'un poids d'une
personne
vu comme ça le visiter je te ne vraie
maladie le stand maladies métaboliques
jeunes maladie qui implique des
changements même des fois au niveau des
quarts m.habib cellule c'est que josé ya
de la recherche sur l'obésité et
l'obésité c'est un réel problème c'est
un problème de santé publique important
certains endroits dans le monde c'est
extrêmement inquiétant aux états unis
entre autres au mexique en amérique du
sud faculté je pense qu'il faut juste
faire attention c'est vrai qu'on devrait
arrêter de go c'est le mandat que leur
poids d'arrêter de tout blanc mais sur
le poids
les gens qui disent qu'ils vivent de
l'aide de la grossophobie puis delà de
la marginalisation la discrimination
c'était rim
j'ai été moi-même en moi même j'ai été
rompant j'étais jeune loti je pesais 200
livres quand j'étais à l'université
whitey fait que je veux dire je sais
exactement c'est quoi le qui fait que
l'on s'entend que je peux pour ça mais
en même temps faudrait pas tomber dans
l'autre extrême où tout d'un coup on dit
que le poids ça a plus aucun rapport
avec la santé puis que
qu'un moment donné on n'accepte plus de
donner des conseils aux gens en lien
avec ce non plus c'est comme ça en ce
moment comme je m'excuse je fais comme
un espèce de gros la youth le meilleur
comme delà c'est comme si tout d'un coup
tout de même tout moment s'il ya quelque
chose des motifs un peu là dedans mais
c'est clair un moment donné si on
commence à dire aux gens l on peut plus
rien dire le tennis comme c'est les gens
peuvent manger ce qu'ils veulent ils
peuvent faire ce qu'ils veulent c'est
plus ici je me dis mais là ça fait des
années qu'on se bat pour des rôles pour
encourager les saines habitudes de vie
je ressors faudrait pas y perdre la vie
faudrait pas le perdre dans le but qu'on
se dit on veut prochain mais le monde je
pense qu'on est capable d'éduquer les
gens aux bonnes habitudes de vie s'en
lécher mais absolument venir écouter
l'extrait en question puis je trouvais
que le discours de bernanke catherine
faisait de 10 ans puis après avoir été
éjectée dans ton émission aussi sur le
sujet et c'est somme toute je trouve que
la pulsion de ton émission plus
l'opposition va pas dans le même sens en
fait le thé que que l'imc c'est pourquoi
la mesure suprême puis que différentes
personnes à différents pauvre être en
santé il a en fait la réalité si la
personne le un médecin justement d'art
dans ton émission je pense qu'ils y
arrivent à la conclusion dans le fond
que le poids santé c'est le point auquel
tu joues ton corps va être quand tu as
des saines habitudes de vie
exo judith mange bien précieux pour tu
vas voir il va être santé que ce soit un
peu plus grand ou mince quoi que ce soit
ça va être bon pour être un bon coup et
adéquat mais je pense qu'une une des
différences si je me trompe que que je
vois c'est que met-on bernanke catherine
ça valait vraiment dire que l'obésité
était pas une pointe cause d'autres
problèmes comme les malades cardiaques
le diabète se méconnaissent comment un
symptôme parmi d'autres qui estime
personnelle et de vie un de ces
symptômes ça va être du pop peut être
visitée parmi d'autres
donc là c'est je pense le rapport cause
à effet qui différent commun qu'ils
perçoivent ce que tu sais c'est possible
je me souviens plus je suis un détail
mais si je pense que le en fait pour moi
l'enjeu là dedans c'est que si l'obésité
en tant que tel c'est vrai c'est pas
juste ici pas aussi l'obésité le concept
c'est juste de dire quand tu vois une
personne qui est dangereux encore plus
gros plus grands tous deux battus 17
personnes là et obèses puis j'ai besoin
de faire une intervention sur elle si
c'est ce ça marche pas ok mais de dire
que l'obésité est un symptôme puis que
ça veut dire que ça dépasse et quoi
qu'ils aient fait dire avec ça si leurs
points c'est bien il faut pas adressé le
poids il faut adresser les habitudes de
vie baisse au jeu totalement d'accord
d'ailleurs en fait c'est ce que j'ai dit
dans mon épisode que ces hommes pointent
quitté outils ce soit il le disco quand
ces sauces c'est correct
le mot je pense que le malaise que
j'essaie plus quand des gens vont dire
par exemple il faut plus parler
d'obésité
parce que si on ne parle de mode obésité
on tenterait de chez mais les gens c'est
où par exemple un autre chose qui moi me
forge particulièrement c'est quand
j'entends jean neige est même citée dans
l'épisode le dans mon épisode que j'ai
faite là-dessus c'est un camp dit toute
forme de perte de poids intentionnelle
ces grosses femmes
c'est donc c'est une personne a perdu du
poids puisque à sa façon en faire
ben dans le fond est grosso femme née
gross aux femmes envers elle-même je
prenne ça qu'on peut pas être grosso
fort envers nous-mêmes j'ai été grosse
pomme avant moi même pendant des années
je détestais mon corps quand j'étais à
thé quand j'étais plus plus gros puis
aujourd'hui je réalise que le problème
était dans ma taille je réponds tu focus
sur mon poids
valeur focus sur mes habitudes de vie
ces pics à ce niveau losc aurait acté
mais mais par contre le côté où on dit
aux jambes imparfait mais là par contre
le travail au niveau des habitudes de
vie faut pas hésiter à le faire par
contre à ce moment à l'heure parce qu'en
ce moment c'est tout comme
elle aussi si on entend aussi des
discours de jean rabel c'est tout une
question troubles alimentaires c'est
juste ça pis on va juste mettre tout le
monde sur l'alimentation intuitive puis
tout va être et de l'épi c'est apprendre
aux gens à manger selon l'heure
selon leur désir puis leur feeling tout
sourit il
et là je pense qu'il est important de
son apporter certaines nuances le sait
les l'obésité c'est un vrai problème
il ya de même de l'obésité infantile qui
est un méchant gros problème a dit
l'aînée qui font juste de tulle je
m'excuse le mispo vrai que c'est un
premier convoi juste réduit en mangeant
et steve mans tout le monde c'est
définitivement un outil est très
important mais c'est pas vrai que ça va
se réduire parce que ce faux pas hésité
à dire ou à dire les vraies affaires aux
gens non plus l'autre l'autre question
qui sous jacente à ce temps là le poids
va être une conséquence des habitudes de
vie oui sauf que le poids vaut aussi à
un certain point venir créer d'autres
problèmes
ouais tu mets ton quelqu'un quelqu'un
qui qui qui est je sais pas ce que
quelqu'un qui est plus lourd qui les
prennent tous genres et en plus de
problèmes de genoux qui vont l'amener à
moins bouger qui vont l'amener à entrer
dans des habitudes de vie - scène fait
que c'est pas vrai que c'est juste un
résultat c'est pas vrai que c'est juste
un effet d'une d'un mode de vie moins 5
c'est aussi en cause de certains
problèmes je sais pas si je m'exprime
bien tu t'exprimes super bien pis si je
peux même te raconter une anecdote par
rapport à ça j'ai eu une conversation
avec une nutritionniste à un moment
donné qui est dans le milieu de
justement anti diète
alimentation intuitive et ses terrains
qui est encore une fois quelque chose
que je suis en ce moment qui lui exposer
ce jeudi au petit matin une personne qui
qu'un poids très important puisque l
avons aussi plan avant son symptôme
c'est de la douleur au niveau des genoux
ok bon je comprends que moi j'ai pas
envie de focus sur son poids ok j'ai pas
envie de faire ce jeu m'a focus et sur
ses habitudes de vie on va faire un
programme d'activité physique tout ça
c'est bien correct mais par contre on
peut tous entendre que son poids ça se
peut que ce soit responsable en partie
du moins de sa douleur au niveau des
genoux et elle a dit non
elle a dit non ces apports rapport la
douleur qui a lieu dans ses genoux c'est
la grossophobie le che comme je
comprends pas au plaza bah oui parce que
les gens souffrent de la grossophobie
vive la discrimination et ça c'est un
pouvoir mener un impact mental est sacré
de la douleur chronique qui est associé
à de la dépression et donc c'est la
personne à la malle ben on le sait que
ça probablement un impact sur ces sur
cette douleur
donc allez peut-être mal au genou à
cause que les gens sont grosso femmes
envers elle rejetait comme bas au québec
peut-être mais on a entendu que ça peut
aussi être que halo 1 60 livres et plus
de trop sur les genoux en fait non plus
j'ai fait
bon ben c'est la fin de la conversation
le j'avais un problème c'est comme des
fois kaki science et une sociologie se
confrontent on dirait que c'est comment
on sait qu'un brin de la société doit ce
fourbi on essaie de le régler mais de
notre côté d'autres problèmes pile c'est
comme ça s'entrechoquent puis ça
fonctionne pas avec la hot line
oui oui tout ça encore une fois là ça
part d'un dote d'une bonne volonté de
changer les choses dit il toute la
culture de la diable si c'est tellement
ancré dans notre société que si c'est
difficile de s'en débarrasser le tipi on
est tous un peu à un moment ou un autre
dans la restriction si tu as mangé des
serbes le thé comme c'est un peu mal
j'en aurai pas ce soir toute cette
culture là est juste dans notre cerveau
outils effet que si je pense c'est ce
fake mouvement guy utile mais
effectivement je pense que comme tu dis
faut distinguer un moment donné
c'est un moment donné il ya aussi des
cons a aussi des connaissances
scientifiques que je pense qu'on peut se
baser là dessus pour donner des bonnes
recommandations sans pour autant mettre
de côté tous ces beaux efforts qui sont
faits au niveau delà de la grossophobie
de la culture de la diète puis tout seul
et moi je pense que c'est un faux
dilemme c'est pour utiliser après un
fort un principe d'esprit critique lost
un faux dilemme
on n'a pas besoin de faire un ou l'autre
on peut faire de la bonne science des
bonnes recommandations et/ou aussi
milité ou être content si l'espèce de
climat social malsain
moi j'ai trouvé ton épisodes sur le
sujet était vraiment bien fait avec
irrespect justement un bon équilibre
parce que si je passais tout comme tu
dis les mouvements illégitime qui comme
tout mouvement comme véganisme est aussi
un autre épisode dans les médias deux
épisodes qui que j'ai préféré la saison
la saison 4
l'autre c'est l'épisode tribeca
d'harmoniser parce que c'est des sujets
super sensible que beaucoup militantisme
et puis beaucoup de discours ces deux
sujets qui se ressemblent dom par
rapport à ce que tu dis le style et la
sociologie pile la santé la science qui
s'entrechoquent et oui exact parce que
justement la transphobie ça existe c'est
un problème où étaient les leurs et oui
comment le régler après c est ce qu on
est ce qu'on balance la séance par la
fenêtre
une manière comme tu dit ça a fonctionné
les deux ensemble je trouve que les deux
épisodes qui te fait ont été faites avec
un boa spitz et espère bien fait dit il
rien toujours rien dit c'est quoi le mot
est par contre à verser lors de
l'attenté épisode mais écoute ça me fait
vraiment vraiment vraiment plaisir que
tu me dis ça parce que moi c'est mes
deux épisodes préférés de la saison
aussi piste aussi deux des épisodes que
je suis plus fier de toute la série
parce que c'est en fait les deux
épisodes qui me terrifiait j'avais super
peur d'aborder ces deux sujets là parce
que j'en avais parlé dans la foi qui
était venu j'en avais parlé avec une
embellie sujet qu'il ne les avait nommés
aux ondes
après le pot cassé ça et puis je veux
mais je vous avais dit que j'avais
vraiment peur puis pourquoi j'avais pas
je n'aurai pas pas de paris avec les
bonnes conclusions scientifiquement
j'avais peur d'eux
tout le monde est un peu à tout le monde
est tellement à fleur de peau que même
si tu arrives avec la bonne information
ça se peut que il ya des gens qui ne
sont juste pas prêts à l'entendre kitty
dans l'épisode sur les bloqueurs
d'hormones à la fin de l'épisode j'ai
fait une entrevue avec un pédiatre qui
travaille dans une clinique de 2,2 de
transition et ses robes du soir et qui
travaille avec des personnes trans bi et
que cette erreur
puis il me disait que à son avis un des
problèmes qu'on a en ce moment c'est ça
c'est que on fait de la recherche on
acquiert des connaissances scientifiques
et après sa folie faire accepter à la
communauté et des fois us la communauté
lgbt qui plus est des fois ces gens là
ils vont avoir l'impression que s'ils
vivent tellement discrimination plus
tellement de marge brute violence que
ils ont l'impression quand tu leur
arrive avec ses connaissances la seii
réagissent un peu et ils ont un peu une
réaction peut ni jake le jeu c'est un
réflexe ou sont comme bon mais c'est
encore une grande institution qui est en
train de vouloir me dire qu'à masquer
mon âge devrait mener ma vie puis ce
pédiatre lui qui faisait de la recherche
mais c'est une des difficultés ça c'est
que tu peux leur amener de la bonne
science mais ils sont tellement habitués
de faire rentrer dedans que leur premier
réflexe est de juste pas vouloir rien
savoir de ce que tu as à leur dire c'est
avec l'équilibré
l'équilibré n'est pas facile à atteindre
je pense que c'est ça que j'avais pas je
me dis je vois tu réussis et puis en au
final je pense que ça donne quelque
chose de quand même correct l'homme est
franchie
en fait c'est quoi ok tout le monde
qu'on était plus par sheila ok c'est
exactement la couleur d'un verre ce que
je pensais qu'elle est forgée dans les
deux cas donc tu es dans le code et
l'épisode soit de la curd hormones moi
j'avais peur de heurter la communauté
trans sais vraiment pas ce que je veux
faire aussi moi j'ai beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de jeu les faite pour eux dans
un sens cet épisode là dessus mais les
gens qui ont été farouche et c'est tout
ce qu'ils sont un peu timides justement
qui n est pas se faire dire que les
bloqueurs d'hormones c'est peut-être
finalement intéressant c'est que je fais
pas confiance à ça je me tais tu
écoutais l'épisode 2 août 2 1 puis dans
le code à la fois de poids même affaire
c'est ça ce que je montre mon écran 10 1
comme ouais je trouve que tu as
minimiser un peu l'impact du pouvoir sur
la santé j'ai fait comme d'autres j'ai
tout fait pour pas faire ça c'est vrai
que j'ai pas heurter la crise politique
que je ne voulais pas rtg art et les
autres que j'avais peur qu'il me faisait
pas partie qui m'inquiétait pas
finalement saisi oui oui c'est à voter
buret
merci beaucoup olivier c'était encore
une fois un plaisir c'est tout le temps
vraiment des belles conversations avec
toi tes notes était notre invité
chouchou il est est le premier outil qui
vient trois fois hélas serait ouais
ouais mais le crime saison mais cool
mais mais sérieusement mois à toutes les
fois qu'on jalouse j'adore nos
conversations c'est tellement stimulant
si je trouve vraiment que vous avez
tellement des bonnes questions puis et
vous considérez vous comme un média
alternatif en étant un podcast en
passant est ce que oui oui c'est la
preuve qu'il ya des médias alternatifs
son bain jusqu'à cerrado cas nous engage
pour faire un podcast qui nous paient
pas contre quartier
voilà ça a été dit merci beaucoup c'est
un plaisir
merci à vous ciao